Egy európai 2023-as talán felmérés
szerint a 14 év felettiek negyede heti
rendszerességgel néz pornót.
Nekem több pornó függő kliensem volt,
akik 14-15 évesek. Tehát nem akkor
találkoztak először, akkor már függők
voltak. Én ahogy így tartom ezeket a
programokat, azt látom, mert azért
látszik, amikor az ember erről kezd
beszélni, hogy kerekedik ki a szemük,
mer nem tudják, miről van szó, és
pislognak, vagy azért már sutyorognak
össze.
Hogy azért ilyen ilyen 10 éves korban
már ez nem kérdés.
Tehát a pornográfiával találkoznak.
Köszöntök minden kedves hallgatót. A mai
nap egy nagyon kemény témával készültem,
mint mindig amúgy egy olyan személyt
hívtam meg, akivel igazi botránykeltő
témáról fogunk beszélgetni. Tudom, hogy
meg fogja borzolni a kedélyeket, de nem
érdekel, mert ezek nagyon fontos
kérdések, és nagyon kíváncsi vagyok a a
mélységeire, a ezeknek a a témáknak a
szexuális nevelésről és az identitásról
fogunk beszélgetni Eberlány Névával.
Üdvözöllek Éva a műsorunkban.
>> Én is köszönöm, hogy itt lehettek és én
is üdvözlöm a kedves nézőket,
hallgatókat.
>> Gyere, kezdjük azzal egy kicsit mutasd
be magad, hogy mióta foglalkozol ezzel a
témával, a szexuális neveléssel, az
identitáskérdéssel.
>> Én úgy szoktam kezdeni a bemutatkozást,
hogy azt mondom, hogy Éberline Éva
vagyok, boldog nő, feleség és három
gyermek édesanyja. Mégpedig azért, mert
ez nem volt mindig ilyen egyszerű.
ugyanis
óvodás koromtól fogva én fiú akartam
lenni, fiúként identifikálódtam mai
szóval, ugye akkoriban még ezek a szavak
nem voltak a múlt században, legalábbis
itt felénk. Aradi vagyok egyébként és
és ugye felnőtt koromig
én én nagyon tehát kívülről azt látták,
hogy fiús vagyok, de én konkrétan
haragudtam, miután megismertem Istent,
hogy létezik.
Konkrétan haragudtam rá, hogy hogy miért
rontott el engem, hogy miért kell nekem
lánynak lennem, és ezzel nagyon sokáig
küzdöttem. Hát ez egy ilyen
háttérinformáció, aminek nagyon sokáig
nem tulajdonítottam jelentőséget.
20 évig foglalkoztam
ifjúságneveléssel, ha tetszik, hat és
25-6 éves kor közöttiek
evangelizációjával.
ifjági lelki gyakorlatokat, táborokat,
képzéseket, kurzusokat, vezetőképzést,
a keresztirányt
nakak az egyik alapítója vagyok és
16 évet ebből főállásban,
és
hét évvel ezelőtt ütött meg ez a téma,
hogy mennyire
mennyire mennyire más lett volna az
életem, ha az a konjunktúra, az a az a
kultúra, ami most azok a hatások, amivel
a mostani 10 évesek találkoznak, az az
én időmben lett volna, akkor
valószínűleg most nem ülnék itt, és nem
mondhatnám azt, hogy boldog nő, feleség
és és három gyermek édesanyja vagyok,
hanem lehet, hogy egészen más irányt
vett volna az életem.
>> Milyen Milyen irányt vett volna
szerinted?
Én egy nonkonformista, lázadó tínédzser
voltam,
és
hát mindig mindent másképp csináltam,
mint ahogy azt kellett, vagy szabad
volt. Na most, hogyha lehetőség lett
volna arra, hogy én fiú legyek,
minden követ megmozgattam volna azért,
akár a szüleim ellenében,
>> hm,
>> hogy én azzá váljak, amivé válhatok. Ma
már tudom, hogy nőből nem lehet férfi.
Azért is állítottam össze ezt a hát ugye
öt dolog, amit minden szülőnek tudnia
kell a nem váltásról, hogy mi történik
akkor, amikor valaki mondjuk egy ilyen
nemváltásban elkezd gondolkodni. Mik
ezek mi ezeknek a fokozata, és milyen
veszélyeket hordoz? Ma már tudom, de egy
10 éves ezt nem tudja, és nagyon sokszor
a szülők sincsenek tisztában ezzel.
Ez egy
furcsa téma, hogy itt Magyarországon és
Erdélyben beszélünk erről, mert én amúgy
az amerikai sajtót meg a a kanadai
sajtót elég eléggé követem, és ott
nyilván, hogy ott tombolt az elmúlt
évtizedben ez a téma, de ez idáig elért
hozzánk, tehát hogy ez egy aktuális téma
a manapság.
>> Igen. Igen. Az a tapasztalatom, ugye én
identitás coachs vagyok. Ez azt jelenti,
hogy hogy azokat, akik az identitásukban
valamilyen téren segítségre szorulnak,
vagy segítséget kérnek, összezavarodnak,
azoknak segítek, és egyre több olyan
szülő keres meg, hogy a gyermeke az
identitásában, az irányultságában
össze van zavarodva.
És beszélgetve ezekkel a tévesekkel, azt
látom, hogy másfél két év késéset tudják
meg a szülők, hogy mi az, ami amiben a
gyermek már benne van.
kicsit visszatérve rád, te
neked mettől meddig tartott ez a ez a
hát ké magadban, vagy harag, ahogy hogy
miért nem lettél fiú, és mikor volt az,
tehát hogy mikor kezdődött, amikor ez
így érezhetően kitapintható volt benned?
És mikor volt az, amikor úgy úgy
megbarátkoztál a feminitásoddal, és és
úgymond hálás lettél újra, hogy mégis
nőnek teremtett Isten?
Azért nehéz az a kérdés, mert egyik sem
egy pillanat műve volt. Hogy mikor
kezdődött, nem tudom,
>> de úgy kábé, tehát hogy a
>> hát én már óvodás koromban csak fiús
dolgokat csináltam. Így visszatekintve
azt tudom talán okként megjelölni, de
ugye ezeket nem tudjuk, hogy édesanyám
fiút akart.
>> Ühüm. És lehet, hogy hogy ez a ugye azt
tudjuk, hogy hogy már a magzati korban
az a az ember veszi az adást, hogy hogy
mit szeretnének, hogyan szeretik őt, mit
várnak tőle.
Tehát az embernek már akkor van tudata,
és ez ma már mérhető.
hogy ez volt-e, nem ez, ezt már majd a
jó Isten megmondja, de hogy tény az,
hogy én óvodás koromtól fogva
így voltam, hogy hogy nem voltam
hajlandó egy szoknyát felvenni, nem
voltam hajlandó babával játszani, csak
olyan dolgokat voltam hajlandó csinálni,
amik amik fiúsak autózni, focizni,
verekedni, lövöldözni
és így tovább. És emlékszem, hogy a
giliszták a fiúkkal együtt ijesztgettük
a lányokat, mert élveztem, hogy
ijesztgetjük a lány, de tehát hogy én én
má nem tartoztam abba a csoportba, úgy
úgy a saját öntudatomat tekintve.
És
és aztán ugye kamaszkorban elkezd jött a
nagy szerelem, párkapcsolat, akkor
szexuálisan bántalmazott a szerelmem 14
évesen.
Akkor nyilván ez rátette a bélyegét a
dologra, hogy milyen rossz, hogy én lány
vagyok, nő vagyok, persze a ciklus sem
segített, hogy mert ha én fiú volnék,
akkor ezzel nem kéne szembesülni, nem
kéne ezzel minden hónapban törődni.
Tehát, hogy volt egy csomó dolog, ami
ezt ezt hol súlyosbította, hol hol
segítette. Én azt tudom mondani, hogy én
a 90% vagyok, hogy a népesség
hagyományosan, mert ez nem most jelent
meg ez a dolog, de hagyományosan. És
akkor mondjuk azt, hogy a digitális tér
előtti korban
ez a népesség 1 3%-át érintette. Tehát
most mondjuk azt, hogy 100 emberből
hármat, és ebből a háromból is
90%-ban
ezt kinőtték. Tehát ahogy az identitás
fejlődik,
úgy megérkezik az ember a saját magához,
az Istentől kapott nemiségéhez,
identitásához. Én ez a kategória vagyok.
Sok minden segített az, hogy nem
ítéltek-e, nem erősítették meg, nem
bátorítottak,
de nem is bántottak úgy különösebben
emiatt, hanem hát ő ilyen, és akkor és
akkor szabad volt nekem annak lennem,
akinek éppen érzem magam. De anélkül,
hogy ez egy erre úgy tekintsek, mint egy
életre szóló pecsét. És azt látom, hogy
sokszor ez a veszély ebben, hogy hogy a
gender ideológia ezt úgy állítja be,
mint egy ilyen genetikai kód, amin
változtatni nem lehet. Hogyha valaki nem
érzi jól magát a bőrében, akkor kötelező
neki az érzéseihez igazodni. És ez egy
hatalmas nagy csapda, mert mindannyian
tudjuk, hogy hogy az érzéseink
változnak, hogy most magam alatt vagyok,
most jó kedvem van, most szomorú vagyok,
most
most nem tudom, most vidám vagyok, most
együttérző vagyok, ezek az érzések, ezek
jönnek, mennek, változnak, az érzésekre
nem lehet építeni.
>> Itt is van egy logikai ellenmondás, mert
az egyik oldalról azt állítják, hogy ez
velünk született, és nem lehet rajta
változtatni. Másik oldalról pedig az,
hogy ez egy kulturálisan
belénkidegződött
valami, amit fiú nevelnek, vagy lánnyá
nevelnek. Most vagy egyik, vagy másik,
tehát vagy Bénink nevelik, vagy így
születünk vele.
>> Ez az egész gender ideológia egy ideoló
egy logikai bukfenc, mert miközben azt
mondják, hogy hogy ugye az ideális nő
meg az ideális férfi nem létezik,
>> ami igaz,
>> ami egyébként Igen, ez ez a része ez
igaz. Hát nem az, hogy ideál nem
létezik, hanem megtestesítve az ideál
nem létezik.
>> Viszont vannak valóban nagyon nőies nők
és nagyon férfias férfiak, és igazából a
nőiesség skáláján
hát nagyon nag hát nagyon széles ez a
skála a nagyon nőies nőtől. A az igazán
nem tudom nagyon határozott és és
karakán nőig. Most akkor így mondom már
nem mintogyha egy nőies nő nem lehetne
karakán most de hogy hogy ez a skála ez
nagyon széles és mindenki mozog
valamennyit ezen a skálán ugyanez a
helyzet a férfiasságnál van a nagyon nem
tudom macsós
férf ilyen nem is tudom most ha azt
mondom férfias férfi akkor a másik
kevésbé férfi tehát hát maszkulin férfi
>> maszkulin fél nem ugyanaz csak más
nyelven de hogy hogy hogy hogy hogy hogy
hogy hogy hogy hogy hogy hogy hogy hogy
hogy hogy hogy hogy hogy hogy van ez a
nagyon most mondhatom azt hogy kanos
férfi és akkor és van a finomabb lelkű,
művészi lelkű, érzékenyebb, empatikusabb
férfi és a kettő között megint
nagyon-nagyon széles a skála. És
mindenki lehet önmaga ott, ahol van. Én
meg vagyok győződve arról, hogy hogy
azok az adottságok, amik amik vannak,
amik bennünk vannak, amiket ki kell
bontakoztatnunk, azok Isten ajándéka.
Tehát az, hogy egy ilyen én egy ilyen
határozott, karakán
nonkonformista,
impulzív személy vagyok, ez nem azért
van, mert én férfi vagyok a szívem
mélyén, hanem csak meg kellett találnom
azt, hogy hogy hol akarja ezt Isten
kamatoztatni. És ebben, amit most
csinálok, ebben ebben igenis
kamatoztatja. nélkül nem tudnék kiállni
emberek elé, vagy nem tudnék itt itt
most válaszolni ezekre a kérdésekre,
hogy hogy az az ajándék, amink van, az
Isten ajándéka, és és az nem nem arról
szól, hogy most akkor férfi vagy nő. Na
de visszatérve a gender ideológia
logikai bukvencéhez, azt mondják, hogy
tagadják a két végletet és azt mondják,
hogy akkor itt egy itt egy skála van, és
itt jön a bookfenc. Ha te nem vagy
kanos, maszkulin férfi, akkor te nő
vagy.
>> Hm.
>> Ha te nem vagy olyan nőies nő, nem érzed
magad olyan nőies nőnek, nem nem vagy
azon a szélén, akkor az biztos azért
van, mert te férfi vagy. Hol a logika
ebben? Nem lehetek önmagam? Nem lehetek
szabad valahol ezen a skálán, ott, ahol
az én helyem van. Nekem meggyőződésem,
hogy meg kell találnunk a helyünket a
bőrünkben, a világban és elsősorban
Isten tervében. És akkor lesz az ember
kiegyensúlyozott, boldog és boldog
kapcsolatokra képes felelősségteljes
felnőtt.
>> Igen, hogy egy kicsit az ördög ügyvédjét
játszam ebben a helyzetben. Valójában én
azt értettem ebből, hogy inkább azt
mondják, hogy ezeket a címkéket kell
elhagyni, hogy nő és férfi, mert
mindenki, aki címkézben van, egy
dobozban van berakva. És hogyha azt
szeretnénk, hogy mindenki megtalálja a
saját identitását, akkor bizonyos
szempontból egy másik címkét kell
hordjon. Vagy pedig lehet, hogy nincs is
arra címke, aminek ő érzi magát valahol
valamilyen a a skálán belül, vagy akár
ha mert a skála az egy dimenziós, de azt
mondjuk, hogy több dimenzióban lehet
gondolkozni már a nemi identitás
szempontjából.
Ez hoza a maga komplexitását és a maga
ellenmondását is egy idő után, de hogy
inkább én ezt érzem benne, hogy hogy
sok-sok címkét kezd gyártani azért, hogy
ne lehessen lényegében aztán egy idő
után címkézni senkit, mert annyi címke
lesz egy idő után, hogy már egyedi
címkéket lehet készíteni, és mindenki a
saját érzése alapján fogja tudni
eldönteni, hogy ma ennek érzem ráadásul
nem csak az, hogy megkaptam a címkét és
és ezzel élek tovább, hanem ha ma ennek
érzem, vagy reggel ennek érzem magam,
akkor estére érezhetem másnak is.
>> Tehát akkor hagyjuk el a címkéket, és
azért, hogy elhagyjuk a címkéket, azért
gyártson két millió címkét.
>> Most akkor melyik az egyszerb a két
címke, vagy a
>> Hát azt hiszem, hogy oda akarnak
eljutni, hogy ne legyen egy idő után
címke. Csak ez a baj, hogy muszáj címke
legyen, mert ha nincsen címke, akkor nem
tudunk beszélgetni. Tehát a a szavaknak
van jelentése. Egy idő után a szavak
elvesztik a jelentésüket, hogyha ha
mindenfele torzítjuk a szavakat.
Én azt gondolom, hogy az, hogy ki vagyok
én, az nem cimke,
hanem hanem az egy hát ugye a az
milyennek ismerem magam, és mennyire
szeretem magam. És ezzel az egésszel az
a probléma, hogy 10 éves korban teljesen
természetes az, hogy egy tínédzser össze
van zavarodva, mert a gyermekkorból tart
a felnőtt korba, és még nem tudja, hogy
ő kicsoda micsoda. Most kezdi keresni,
mert eddig Anyuci apuci gyermeke volt,
és és ott biztonságban volt, és ott ön
maga tudott lenni, és az öt éves
kislány, nézzük meg, milyen bájosan tud
pörögni a kis szoknyácskájába, és semmi
baja nincs azzal, hogy ő kislány a
legtöbb esetben, de ha van is, az sem
probléma egyébként.
A kisfiucska is ügyesen tud játszani.
Nincsen neki még problémája
gyermekkorban, de jönnek a elindulnak a
hormonok, és ugye egy csomó változáson
megy keresztül ez a tínédzser, megnyílik
a keze, lába, megváltozik a a az
egyensúly
ja, és ettől még a járása is
bizonytalan. Ö ezenkívül ugye elkezd ö
megpróbálni megfelelni a a külső, tehát
ugye már nem csak anyuci, apuci, hanem
egyre nagyobb hatása van a a
kortársaknak,
egyre nagyobb hatással van rá a
közösségi média, meg kell felelni,
nehogy bántsanak, mert ugye otthon
biztonságban vagyok, ott önmagam
lehetek, ott hisztizhetek, mert akkor is
szeretnek,
és kell, hogy biztons tehát kell legyen
egy hely, ahol biztonságban vagyok, de
kilép ebből a biztonságból, és belép egy
olyan közegbe, ahol nem tudja, hogy most
vajon-e így szeretnek vagy nem
szeretnek. Ha ezt csinálom, jobban
szeretnek. Ha azt csinálom, akkor jobban
szeretnek. Nem merek megszólalni, nehogy
utána elkezdjenek
piszkálni, zaklatni. A digitális
gátlásztés folyamata miatt ez a
digitális térben felerősödik, és
óhatatlanul is visszajön, ha gondolom
erről is beszélgethetünk, hogy
óhatatlanul kijön a képernyőről ez a
fajta viselkedés, ez a fajta
kommunikáció. Tehát van mitől félnie, ez
is zavart okoz. A hormonális változás
nem egyik napról a másikra történik,
hanem idő kell a testnek, a
szervezetnek, hogy beálljon az, hogy
neki személy szerint, tehát hogy az ő
genetikai felépítéséhez
milyen helyzetben, milyen mennyi
hormont, most nagyon egyszerűen
leegyszerűsítve a dolgot, mennyit kell
adagolni. De ebben a az időszakban, amíg
ez a beállás történik, eddig addig
össze-evissza, hol sokat, hol keveset.
Emiatt érzelmileg is ingadozik.
Személyisége válogatja, hogy kinél
mennyire extrémek ezek az érzelmi
ingadozások.
Vagy vagy gyengébbek. Ugye ez is
változó. Tehát látjuk azt, hogy rengeteg
változó tényező veszi körül a
tínédzsert. Így egyik hónapról a másikra
kvázi.
Nincs már abban a biztonságos közegben,
amiben gyermek korábban volt. Ennyi
mindennel kell szembenéznie.
Érthető, hogy frusztrált, hogy szorong,
hogy nehéz neki, és keresi a megoldást.
Na most hagyományosan
ezekkel meg kellett küzdeni. Tehát az
ember megküzdötte
ezt a változást, át átment rajta,
megküzdötte az érzelit, megtanulta
birtokba venni, megtanult uralkodni
magán, mert ugye a társadalom nem
engedte, nem lehetett csak úgy
visszapofázni
30 évvel ezelőtt, mert jött a saller, és
most nem a saller
mellett érvelek, hanem csak, hogy volt
valamilyen módja a társadalomnak arra,
és most nem csak a sallerra gondolok,
hanem arra, hogy így nem illik
viselkedni.
Tehát én nekem elég, ha ránézek a
gyerekre, nem kell ránézek, és abból ő
tudja, hogy ezt így nem. De kimegy, ott
ott nem néznek úgy rá, hogy és igazából
itt a határokról van szó, hogy határokat
szabunk annak, hogy mit lehet és mit
nem, hogyan lehet viselkedni és hogyan
nem. Ez megengedett. Ez nem nem tudja
még a gyermek. Most tanulja a 10 éves,
hogy mi mi mitől szemtelenség ez.
Nem tudja. Tehát ezeket meg kell
tanítani, de ha nincs, aki tanítsa, és
ma nincs, aki tanítsa, mert jaj, nehogy
megbántsuk a gyereket, és nehogy hogy
hogy a a kis érzelmei, nehogy sérülést
szenvedjen meg, aztán traumatizál, nem
lesz traumatizált a gyerek attól, hogy
valaki megtanítja őt arra, hogy így nem
lehet viselkedni. Az a dolgunk, hogy
megtanítsuk, és neki az a dolga, hogy
ezeken az érzelmi hullámzásokon, ezen az
időszakon úgy menjen végig, hogy mire
felnő, addig megtanul uralkodni magán,
megtudja, hogy milyen helyzetben mit
lehet, mit illik, mit szabad, mit nem,
mit engedhet meg magának. Mert nyilván
ha én bemegyek a munkahelyemre és a
főnökömmel úgy beszélek, mint otthon a
gyerekkel, mikor felbosszant, nem sokáig
maradok ott. Tehát, hogy hogy milyen
szerepben mit engedhetek meg magamnak,
ezt meg kell tanulni. És a kamaszkor, a
serdülő kor ennek az ideje, hogy ezt ezt
meg kell tanulni.
zavartak, frusztráltak, nincsenek
határok sok esetben.
A megküzdés helyett ezért sokszor azt
választják, hogy menekülnek.
Hova menekülnek? A digitális térbe, mert
ott bárki lehetek. Ott mutathatok
magamról egy olyan ideális ént,
amilyen lehet, hogy sosem leszek, de
arra kapom a lájkokat. Ott engem
értékelnek ezért. Milyen jó, hogy te ezt
bevállaltad. Milyen jó, hogy te ezt
kimondtad. Milyen hogy tisztelünk téged
azért, hogy te kiersz állni és bármi,
vagy éppen bulingolják, hogy jaj ne már
izé, és akkor ne hadd ne mondjam, hogy
hogy milyen kifejezéseket használnak. Ö
>> mielőtt belemegyünk ezekbe a témákba,
kicsit összefoglalnád azt, hogy te
hogyan éled a mindennapjaidat, mivel
foglalkozol?
>> Hát úgy élem a mindennapjaimat, hogy van
két kicsi gyermekem.
meg van egy férjem, és hát ugye a
reggelek azzal telnek, hogy a hogy a
család elrendeződik, mindenki eljut abba
az intézménybe, ahova való. A nagy
gyermek, ő már intézi magát, azzal már
nem kell foglalkozni.
És
két irányú a az a amivel foglalkozom a
munkám. egyfelől identitás coachsként
vannak kliensek,
fiatalkorúak és felnőttek, akiknek akár
identitásbeli, akár párkapcsolatbeli
nehézségeik vannak, olyan időszakon
mennek át, hogy segítségre van
szükségük, és akkor
akkor vannak olyan napok, amikor be van
osztva, hogy hogy akkor velük
beszélgetek, hogy ezt azért nem nevezem
tanácsadásnak,
hanem coachingnak, mert nem tanácsot
adok. Ugye én nem tudom, hogy te ki
vagy.
Az edzőnek az a dolga, coach azt
jelenti, hogy edző, ez edzőnek az a
dolga, hogy segítsen a versenyzőnek
kihozni magából a maximumot.
És identitás coachsként én is ezt
teszem. kísérem a klienst, hogy hogy ő
megtalálja azt, hogy ki ő legbelül, és
hogy jóba legyen magával, jól érezze
magát a bőrében. Annyira szeretem ezt a
magyar kifejezést, hogy jól vagyok a
bőrömben.
Ö, vagy ha párkapcsolati problémái
vannak, akkor akkor pedig ebben, hogy
tudjon ő abban a párkapcsolatban úgy
jelen lenni, hogy hogy
feldolgozza, megdolgozza, ö
ki kiengesztelődjön,
ki egyensúlyba kerüljön az a az a
kapcsolat. Az időm másik fele pedig
azzal telik, hogy hát ugye kutatom
ezeket a témákat, amikről ugye könyveket
is írtam, és előadásokra, tréningekre
készülök, előadásokat tartok kurzusokat,
tréningeket tartok, vannak online
tréningek is, ugye, ami amit azért
azért készítettem, mert ugye amikor
otthon voltam a két kicsivel, tudtam
azt, hogy én én én nem tudok leülni,
megnézni vagy meghallgatni egy ilyen
több órás valamit. És ezek az online
tréningek úgy vannak összeállítva, hogy
egy kisgyermekes is meg tudja nézni,
mert ilyen 15-20 perces, nagy ritkán 25
perces kis videók vannak. Van hozzá
munkafüzet, hogy akkor a házaspár otthon
beszéljék meg, döntsék el, hogy ők ezt
hogy csinálják. Én nem tudom, minden
család más, minden gyerek más. És ezért
úgy gondolom, hogy vannak dolgok, amiket
fontos tudnunk, és van amit pedig mi
hozzáigazítunk a mi családi
értékrendünkhöz, a mi személyiségünkhöz,
a gyermekeink személyiségéhez,
vérmérsékletéhez, az időrendünkhöz. És
akkor ezek az online tréningek így
vannak felépítve, tehát ilyeneket. És
akkor ezen kívül vannak az offline
előadások, kurzusok, amikre nyilván
készülők nagyon sok időt felvesz a
szervezés, az adminisztráció,
az emberi méltóság központot is vezetem,
azzal is van feladat. Tehát, hogy ilyen
ilyen nagyon sok az adminisztrációs
munka.
A podcasten víziója az volt az elmúlt
közel két évben, hogy az alapelveket
körbejárjam, és mindenféle érdekes
emberrel tudjak leülni, és mélyebben
megérteni azokat a bölcsességeket,
amelyeken a világ alapszik. Rengeteg
izgalmas beszélgetésben volt részem az
elmúlt időszakban. Közel 40 epizódot
forgattunk le. Ezeknek a költségei
körülbelül olyan 100€ per forgatás. Én
úgy gondolom, hogy bármi, ami értékes,
az önfenntartható kell tudjon lenni. És
elérkezett az idő ahhoz, hogy
támogatókat vonjak be. És hogyha neked
is értékes ez a podcast, akkor segíts,
hogy együtt tudjuk fenntartani. Az én
vállalásom az, hogy újabb és újabb
izgalmas epizódot fogok készíteni.
Kérlek, segíts, hogyha tetszik ez az
epizód, hogy ezt együtt tudjuk
folytatni. Minden egyes epizód
leírásában megtalálod a Patreon linket,
a Patreon keresztül pedig támogatni
tudsz majd ebben. Most éppen egy turnéak
a kellős közepén, vagy pontosabban a
végén, vagy milyen stációi vannak? Mi
mikről tartasz előadásokat ebben ezen a
turné?
>> Nagyon sok iskolában jártam. Ott a
tínédzsereknek tartottam digitális tükör
programot. Ez egy olyan gyakorlatilag
programsorozat 10 téma van benne, ami a
azzal foglalkozik, hogy mivel
találkoznak a 10 évesek a digitális
térben, és az milyen hatással van rájuk.
Kezdve azzal, hogy az az
identitásfejlődés hogy működik mihatra.
egyébként nagyon tudják, ezek interaktív
foglalkozások, és sokszor ki van adva,
hogy akkor ti beszéljétek meg,
döntsétek-e, írjátok össze, hozzátok
hozzátok ki, csináljátok meg. Ms érdekes
az, hogy a fej fejben tudják, hogy mit
nem szabad megosztani.
Tehát majdnem minden csoport felírja,
hogy intim képet nem osztunk meg. De
aztán amikor elkezdünk erről beszélni,
ugye ezt sexingnek hívjuk ezt a ezt a
jelenséget, amikor intim képeket kérnek,
küldenek egymásnak a tívesek. egyébként
ez nagyon gyakori. Tehát
hetedik-nyadiktól már már trend. M akkor
azért megnézzük például egy ilyen képnek
a történetét, hogy honnan hova jut el,
hogy azzal mi lesz, hogy mit kell
ilyenkor csinálni. Szóval 10 ilyen téma
van ebben a programsorozatban. Ezzel
jártam iskolákba ötödiktől 12-ig,
hát ötödik osztálytól 12. osztályig. Ez
volt az egyik nagy része ennek a
turnéak. A másik pedig, hogy szülőknek
tartottam előadásokat a szexuális
nevelésről. Hát ez is nyilván különböző
korosztályt, a kisebbek szexuális
nevelése, a kamaszok szexuális nevelése
és
volt egy legyél igazi lelki gyakorlatzus
tínédzsereknek. Ez arról szól, hogy hogy
kinek gondolom magam én, és hol találom
meg a valódi identitásomat, és mi köze
van Istennek ehhez az egészhez. Ez egy
egynapos kurzus volt itt Udvarhelyen.
És mi volt még? Vagy a szakemberképzés.
Tehát
sok helyre hívnak ezzel a digitális
tükörrel, különösen is itt Erdélyben.
Itt itt egy kicsit valahogy
tudatosabbak a szülők, felnőttek, hogy
jobban látják, vagy komolyabban veszik
ezeket a veszélyeket, de nem tudok
mindenhova elmenni, ezért most van
jelenleg három csapat, négy csapat
a Marosvásárhelyi csapatnak tartottam
most
képzést, ahol volt egy katolikus, egy
református, egy adventista
ifjúsági vezetőkből álló csapat is
voltak pedagógusok. Nekik adtam át
gyakorlatilag ezt a képzést, hogy akkor
most már ők is tudják ezt tartani
iskolákban vagy ifi órákon vagyokban.
>> Tehát akkor gyakorlatilag lefeded ötödik
osztálytól a spektrumot egészen
felnőttekig és szakemberekig.
>> Igen.
>> A hallgatóim nagy része 25-től 55 éves
korúakig van. Úgyhogy arra gondoltam,
egy kicsit közelítsük meg a felnőttek
perspektívája. Mi az, amit mi felnőttek
nem tudunk a gyermekeinkről? Hol hol
vannak a gyermekeink? Milyen közegben
vannak nap mint nap? Mire figyeljünk így
felnőttek?
>> Hát, hogy melyik gyerek hol van, azt nem
tudom, de azt látom, hogy ugye fel
szoktam mérni egy-egy ilyen programon,
elég sok helyen voltam már, most is így
több 100 diákkal volt dolgom. Fel
szoktam mérni, hogy hány órát töltenek
online.
Borzasztó,
borzasztó. Tehát, hogy hogy átlagosan
négy-öt órát az NMHHHHH, tehát Nemzeti
Médés Hírközlési Hatóság Magyarországon
mérte, ugyanerre jutottak, hogy az
iskolán kívül, mert ugye ott
Magyarországon már nem lehet iskolába
bevinni eszközöket jó esetben,
öt órát töltenek átlagosan a digitális
térben. Tehát ha az a kérdés, hogy hol
vannak a gyerekek az iskola és a
lefekvés között, nagy valószínűséggel az
online térben, a digitális térben, és
hát, hogy ott mivel találkoznak,
az elég borzasztó.
>> Mivel találkoznak?
>> Hát mindennel is, amit a szülő nem
szeretne.
Vegyük sorba.
>> Vegyük sorba, listázzuk, nézzük.
>> V jó.
Hát a pornográfiával nagyon korán
találkoznak. Egy európai 2023-as talán
felmérés szerint a 14 év felettiek
negyede
heti rendszerességgel néz pornót.
Nekem több pornó függő kliensem volt,
akik 14-15 évesek, tehát nem akkor
találkoztak először, akkor már függők
voltak.
Én ahogy így tartom ezeket a
programokat, azt látom, mert azért
látszik, amikor az ember erről kezd
beszélni, hogy kerekedik ki a szemük,
mert nem tudják, miről van szó, és
pislognak, vagy azért már sutyorognak
össze.
Hogy azért ilyen ilyen 10 éves korban
már ez nem kérdés.
Tehát a pornográfiával találkoznak. Na
most nagyon sok felnőtt azt gondolja,
hogy ja hát pornó, hát mi is
találkoztunk vele, hát nagy ügy. Csak
azt nem tudatosítják, hogy míg mondjuk a
múlt században született,
>> Milyen rosszul hangzik múlt században.
Igen,
>> te is az vagy. Én is. A múlt században
született
felnőttek
amivel találkoztak. Hát el kellett menni
a szomszédfaluban megvenni azt az
újságot, és valahol titokban a
többiekkel megnézni, és akkor ott voltak
valami képek, ami amik izgalmat
keltettek az emberben, vagy mondjuk
akkor a század végét vegyük, akkor már
VHS kazetták voltak, amit szintén el
kellett menni valahova máshova, ahol nem
ismerték az embert, mert ugye szégy
dolog, hogy akkor ki kibérelt valaki
egyet, és akkor azt ott úgy megnézni,
hogy ne kapjon rajta senki. És akkor
általában ezek a felvételek, ezek
ábrázoltak
egy férfit meg egy nőt, valahogy
találkozták, ezt a részt nem tudom, nem
hozták túl hosszan, hogy aztán legyen a
a lényeg. Régen ugye a szoft porn az
volt, amikor meztelen alakokat mutattak,
és valamilyen
a a szexuális eseményt idéző mozgást
végeztek, de konkrétan a behatolás nem
látszott.
azt nevezték akkor hardnak, amikor
konkrétan behatolás is látszott, meg
meg egyéb tevékenységek. Na most ez az
elmúlt 20 évben nagyon megváltozott,
ugyanis ma az számít szoftnak, amikor a
behatolás látszik, és csak egy férfi meg
egy nő, felnőtt férfi, felnőtt nő van
együtt. Ez a ritka, tehát ez a 10%
egy 2017-esen
évvel ezelőtti
kutatás vizsgálta a legnézettebb pornó
jeleneteket, és azt találták,
hogy a jelenetek 88%-a
erőszakot tartalmaz, konkrétan
folytogatást,
ütést, verést, verbális agressziót a
férfitól, a nő irány ányába 97%-ban.
Na most
ezzel találkoznak a gyerekek, tehát
felmennek a netre, hogy megnézzék, hogy
hogy kell szexelni, mert ugye már
készülnek ők készül nagyon készülnek a
párkapcsolatra, és azt gondolják, hogy
ez ez a párkapcsolat. Mit találnak ott?
Jó esetben egy felnőtt férfit és egy
felnőtt nőt, akik erőszakosan
közösülnek.
És azt gondolják, ezt így kell csinálni.
Konkrétan ismerek olyan tínédzsert,
akit a párja folytogatott, és neki
lelkiismeret furdalása volt, hogy ő ezt
nem élvezi. Hölgyről van szó, mert ez a
norma, és ebben ez a legveszélyesebb,
hogy normalizálódik
a szexuális kapcsolaton belüli erőszak.
Ez elvárás, és ha valaki nem élvezi,
akkor vele van a probléma. Nyilván akik
ilyen videókat néznek bennük meg
kialakul ez az igény, hogy hogy akkor jó
a szex, ha ilyen. Miért mondtam azt,
hogy jó esetben ez? Azért, mert nagyon
gyakran találkoznak kiskorúak ellen
elkövetett szexuális abúzussal. Tehát,
hogy hogy gyerekkel, öreggel, halottal,
állattal, egyneműek,
többen, sokan
és mindent is csinálnak a közös ülésen
túl részletezem. Igen, igen. Hát
próbálom megemészteni érzelmileg, de
nagyon gyorsan nagyon gyors tempót
nyomsz, de de erről akarok beszélni,
úgyhogy még egyszer vesz a sorrendet
gyerekkel, halottal, gyerekkel, öreggel,
halottal,
>> állattal,
>> halottal,
>> halottal.
>> Hol hol lehet ilyen videót?
>> Én én a felméréseket nézem. Jó, tehát
bog, én nem fogyasztó vagyok, hanem
hanem hanem én én a a kutatások. Tehát
az a helyzet, hogy tényleg ez van fent
az interneten, ezzel találkoznak a
gyerekek. A vannak ilyen oldalak, ahol
ahol lehet jelenteni a gyerekek ellen
elkövetett abzusokat, és az Inhope
oldalán, ha jól emlékszem, kettő most
nincsenek előttem a számok.
előadásokon kizoktam ugye vetíteni, és
akkor kicsit puskázok, már
megtanulhattam volna, milyen sokszor
tartottam, de ha jól emlékszem, 2023-ban
az inhopehoz beérkezett jelentések
a gyermekbántalmazás
vonatkozásában
64%-ban
3 és 13 éves gyerek ellen elkövetett
szexuális abúzust
ábrázoltak az oda beérkezett jelentések.
Ö volt egy szelet, ami három év alatti
gyerekek ellen elkövetett abúzusokat
ábrázoltak. Pornográfiáról beszélünk, és
egy nagyon kicsi szelet az, ami 13 és 18
év közöttiek ellen elkövetett szexuális
abúzust ábrázolnak. Ezzel találkoznak a
gyerekek másfelől. Ugye már nem csak a
stúdiókban
filmezett pornó van, hanem aem ez is
23-as felmérés. hogy a az interneten
felelhető friss tartalmak, tehát a
222-ben
vagy 23-ban beérkezett friss pornográf
tartalmak, az újakat vizsgálták 64%-ban
otthon készült,
tehát nem stúdióban, otthon készült
felvételeket
ábrázolnak. Tehát, hogy van egy ilyen
egy ilyen shift, egy ilyen átalakulás a
pornó ö
iparban,
vagy nem tudom ezt hogy nevezzem, hogy
már nem annyira a ugye a
professzionálisan elkészített felnőtt
tartalom dominál, hanem egyre inkább a
gyerekek által, maguk által készített,
beküldött
és gyerekeket ábrázoló, vagy
tíédzsereket ábrázoló pornográf tartalm
kezdenek
többségbe kerülni ezeken a platformokon,
de hogy ezeket bárki elérheti. Tehát én
úgy tudtam, hogy ezt keményen üldözik,
hogy pedofil
videókat.
>> Hát persze, hát persze.
Az a helyzet, hogy Amerikában több
államban bevezették már a az életkor
életkor szabályozás. Most nem jutt
eszembe a megfelelő kés.
>> De most nem arra gondolsz, amikor be
kell csekkelni 18 elmúltan.
>> Nem, nem arra gondolok, amit azért csek,
hanem hanem amikor konkrétan biometriai
minek hívják ezt? Amikor felmutatod a
szeméidet és ellenőrzik a szemé
>> vagy Igen. A személyidet
ilyen ilyen arcoddal, az
újlanyomatoddal, tehát ellenőrzi
konkrétan azt, hogy te hány éves vagy.
Na most amelyik államokba bevezették ezt
az életkor ellenőrzést,
>> azokból az államokból ezek a ezek a nagy
pornó
vállalatok kivonultak.
>> Miért? Mert a fő felhasználók már a
gyerekek.
Hogy vált pár évtized alatt ennyire
durvábbvá a helyzet?
>> Hát úgy, hogy még az újságíér el kellett
menni a szomszédfaluba, vagy a VHS
kazettáért, úgy ma a gyerekek kezében
van az eszköz. Azt kell tudni, hogy
gyakorlatilag minden olyan képernyő, ami
internethez kapcsolódik, alkalmas arra,
hogy pornót lehessen nézni rajta. Most
extrémet mondok. A hűtő okos hűtőnek a
kijelzője is alkalmaz rá. Az autónak a
ki Beül az autóba a gyerek
és ott eléri a pornót.
Ott eléri a pornót. A Defend Young Minds
oldalon
vannak nagyon brutális
dolgok és nagyon-nagyon jó tanácsok
szülőknek, hogy ezt hogyan kerüljék el.
És és ott tényleg mindig nagyon frissen
hozzák a legújabbat. Figyeljetek oda
erre és figyeljetek oda erre. Ez a
legújabb. Szóval a Defend Young Minds,
bocsánat, a Defend Young Minds oldal
nagyon ugye angolul nagyon hasznos
tanácsokat tud adni szülőknek. Nem
véletlenül mondja mindig PT Lákos, hogy
amikor akkor adjál okos telefont a
gyerek kezébe, ha szeretnéd, hogy pornót
lásson. Mondok egy saját sztorit. Kedves
ismerősünk,
ugye öt éves kislánynak születésnapja
volt. nem tudtunk elmenni a
születésnapra, ezért néhány nappal előbb
elmentünk, és akkor a jó képek, rossz
képek című könyvet vittük ajándékba, ami
óvodásoknak a pornográfiára való
felkészítés nyilván nem pornoképeket
tartalmaz, hanem elmagyarázza azt, hogy
vannak intim testrészek, ugye fürdő
ruharuha, tehát onnan lehet tudni, hogy
amit kimegyünk a strandra, a
fürdőruhabal, amit eltakarunk, az intim
testrész, és hogy vannak jó képek a
nagymamáról, a kiskutyáról, tájképek,
nem tudom, meg vannak rossz képek,
amikor
amikor ezeket az intim testrészeket
mutatják, és ezt nevezzük
pornográfiának, óvodás szinten, ez
teljesen érthető, minden gyerek érti,
tudja, a az enyémek is már négy évesen
tudták. Ugye ennek a kislánynak is
elmagy mit kell csinálni? Hát azt, hogy
elmész onnan, nem nézed meg, elmész
onnan és szólsz anyának, apának, hogy te
ilyet láttál, neked ilyet mutatott
valaki. Ugye más néven bugyizabálynak is
nevezik, hogy hogy nem mutatod, nem
nézed, ha valaki ilyet akar mutatni vagy
nézni, akkor szólsz. Ezt óvodás korban
fontos megtanítani, mert a gyerekek
kíváncsiak, és már óvodában is játszanak
orvosisat, és ösztönösen tudják, hogy
ahhoz bunkit kell építeni, hogy ne
lássam más, hogy mi most itt mit
játszunk. Na most ennek a kislánynak
elvittük ezt a könyvet, elolvastuk,
megbeszéltük együtt, biztosra mentem,
és néhány nappal később volt a
kislánynak az ötödik születésnapja,
és hát ugye a szülők beszélgettek a
teraszon az asztalnál, a gyerekek egy
kicsit odébb játszottak, és este mondja
a kislány az anyukának, kétségbeesetten
hívott fel anyuka utána, hogy hogy ő
látott rossz képet. Hát de hol? Hát
egész nap együtt voltunk, vendégek. Nem,
hát mit láttál? És akkor elmesélte, hogy
a hat éves kisfiú kölcsön kérte az apuka
telefonját egy pár percre.
Nem volt neki saját eszköze, de az
apukáét néha megkapta. És a hat éves
kisfiú mutatott pornót a mind a többi öt
öt éves gyereknek ott néhány méterre a
szülőktől, úgyhogy a szülők semmit sem
tudtak. Mit gondolsz, hány gyerek szólt
a szülőnek róla?
Az az egy,
>> az az egy, akit előre felkészítettek rá.
Ezért az a mottó, hogy legyél te az
elsődleges forrás gyermeked számára,
mert az agyunk úgy működik, hogy az
elsődleges információ lesz az origó,
ugye? És ahhoz kapcsolódik, ami később
jön, és az szűrőként tud funkcionálni.
Tehát ha én beszélek előbb a
szexualitással a gyerekről, az én
értékrendemet adom át a gyermeknek
idejében, hat éves kor előtt, mert
látjuk, ő már öt évesen találkozott vele
egy a saját születésnapján, a saját
családjának az otthonába.
Tehát ha ha én adom át előbb, az lesz a
szűrő, és utána jönnek a többiek,
mutatnak, mondanak mit tudom én, az az
megszűri. Tehát egy az, hogy
információt, stratégiát adjunk a
gyereknek, ma egy egy elengedhetetlen
dolog. Tehát a tabusítás olyan luxus,
amit nem engedhetünk meg magunknak, ha
azt akarjuk, hogy a gyermekünk
identitása, nemisége, a kapcsolat
képessége egészségesen fejlődjön.
>> Na gyere, adjunk eszközt a szülőknek is.
Ilyenkor mit tudunk mondani az öt éves
gyermekünknek? Kezdjük ott, hogy mi a
különbség a szexuális nevelés és a
szexuális felvilágosítás között, mert
mert a legtöbb ember a szexuál Nem,
akkor most én kérdezek, mit gondolsz, mi
az a szexuális felvilágosítás és mi az a
szexuális nevelés?
>> Hát gondolom az egyik ez egy egyszeri
alkalom, a másik pedig egy folyamatos.
Tehát a nevelésben benne van egy
folyamat, egy egy folyamatos
ottlét a gyermek mellett. És
Igen, igen,
>> igen. Alapjáraton
>> meleg, közeledik.
>> Közel, közel van, közel van. Igen,
meleg. Szóval a nagyon jó, nagyon fontos
és nagyon jó a szexuális felvilágosítás.
A szexuális felvilágosítást
én egy fűszercsomaghoz szoktam
használni, grillfűszer, halffűszer, mit
tudom én, forralt borfűszer.
És akkor ugye egy ilyen csomagban
sokféle dolog van benne, pont úgy, hogy
az jó legyen. Na most nagyon-nagyon jó
felvilágosító programok vannak. A
cikluss show, titkos küldetés, chain,
ténure
fashiont is én ide sorolnám. Ének felit
nem tudom, hogy mi micsoda. Úgyhogy ha
ilyen szavakat használsz, akkor kérlek
egy kicsit fejts ki nekem, hogy mi ez a
Pure Fashion például
>> a Pure Fashion az a magyarországi Regnum
Kristi közösségnek a a programja. A
lányokat
>> programok. Igen. Lányoknak segít abban,
hogy divatosan, csinosan, de mégis
tartózkodóan
ízlésesen
öltözzenek. Ön azt szoktam mondani, hogy
úgy, hogy a fiú rád legyen kíváncsi, és
ne csak gerjedjen.
>> Ühüm. Jó, szóval térjünk vissza, mit
mondhat mit mit mondhatnak a szülők
akkor egy öt éves gyermeknek? Ö
>> én azt mondom, hogy nulla éves kortól
kell kezdeni az alapokkal. A
testrészeket fontos megtanítani. A nem
azt, hogy csak nuni, kuki, puca, punci,
fütyi, nem tudom, minden ugye mindenhol
másképp nevezik ezeket.
Ez nagyon jó, meg nagyon vicces, de ha
csak így nevezzük a nemi szerveket,
akkor mikor fogunk átváltani a valós
nevükhöz? Én azt mondom, hogy emellett
fontos gyakran vagy akár többet
használni a rendes elnevezésüket. És
amikor tisztába teszem a gyereket, akkor
már elkezdhetem
megtanítani őt arra, hogy most
megtisztítom a a hímvesződet, hogy ez az
előbőr, ez a mak, ez a herezacskó, a
lányokat szeméremt, szemérem ajkak,
hüvely,
csikló Ahogy egy kicsit nagyobbak,
vannak ilyen nagyon jó kis ö akár
biológia biológiailag korrekt
füzetek, vagy ugye most ezt a
mesekönyvet is azért írtuk, hogy hogy
ugye vannak belső szervek a lány Áoknak
a petefészek, petevezeték méheket
öt éves kor előtt fontos megtanítani. És
ugye azt is, ahogy az előbb mondtam,
hogy ezek intim testrészek, hogy melyek
az intim testrészek,
és hogy ezeket nem mutatjuk senkinek,
mert ez kincs. Istentől azért kaptuk,
hogy az ő munkatársai legyünk az élet
továbbadásában. A legnagyobb dolog, a
legnagyobb érték az élet.
És ezt óvodás kortól fogva megtanítjuk,
amikor kimegyünk kirándulni, nem
tapossuk el a bogarat, nem törjük le a
fa levelét, tiszteljük az életet minden
formában. Ez szexuális nevelés. Amikor
leülök a a gyerekkel, elolvasok egy
mesékem Bibliából elolvasok egy
történetet, és ott Noé történette. És
hogy miért kellett az állatoknak párban
menniük? Hát azért, hogy tovább tudják
adni az életet, és hogy az élet
továbbadásához kell egy hím meg egy
nőstény, egy férfi meg egy nő, hogy az
élet továbbadása a házasságon belül van.
Ezek mind olyan dolgok, amiket öt éves
kor előtt fontos ezzerszer elmondani,
mert ugye a szexuális felvilágosítás az
a kombó. Viszont a nevelést én a sóhoz
hasonlítom. Próbáltál már egy nap
nélkül?
>> Biztos. Igen. Igen.
>> És milyen volt? Hát
egyrészt a víz kimegy az emberből, tehát
a sóak van egy ilyen megtartó ereje is.
És a másik az, hogy hogy például amikor
bö vytölök só nélkül, akkor
nagyon-nagyon megviseli a testemet,
tehát hogy fáj a fejem, nyügös vagyok.
Szóval érzem azt, hogy van különbség a
só és a nem só között. Tehát egy
pohársós víz megívásával sokkal könnyebb
egy egész napot túlpöjtölni, vagy
átböjtölni, mint mint só nélkül. És
ezenkívül íztelen az élet, az étel,
tehát hogy hogy ugye ösztönösen minden
mindenhez, ha szinte hát jó, hát
sütemény még a süteményekbe is azt még
egy csöbb só j jobban kihozza az ízeket.
Igen. Tehát, hogy a sót minden napáj a
szexális nevelés a az a mindennapokról
szól arraó minden nap és ezeket
elmondjuk ezzerszer, mert azt, hogy vedd
már fel a cipődet, vagy hogy a piros
lámpánál megállunk, azt is ezerszer
elmondjuk a gyereknek és ez a nem hiszem
el, hogy még mindig nem tudja, hogy meg
kell állni. Na most ugyanez vonatkozik a
szexuális nevelésre, az intim
testrészekre, arra, hogy ezt nem nézik,
nem mutatjuk, nem adjuk,
szólunk tehát ezekre, ezekre a
szabályokra.
Mi van akkor, hogyha egy szülő azt
mondja, hogy én már egy picit elkéstem a
gyermekem, már 10 éves, és már zéró
évesen el kellett volna kezdjem. Mit tud
csinálni ilyenkor egy szülő?
Hát elkezdi, elkezd beszélgetni erről.
>> Nem túl késő?
>> Nem, soha nem késő. Soha nem késő. volt
olyan résztvevő
tréningen, akinek már 19-20 évesek
voltak a a gyermekei, és hát hát azért
eljött, hogy hátha, és mondta, hogy
hazament, és muníciót adott neki arra,
hogy hogy hogy akkor kezdjen el
beszélgetni. Tehát nyilván
jobb korábban elkezdeni amiatt, amivel
találkoznak a mai gyerekek.
De soha nem késő elkezdeni ezekről
beszélgetni.
>> Emlékszem, hogy egyszer édesanyám
próbálkozott valami hasonlóval. Már nem
is tudom, hogy hány éves voltam, de már
mindenesetre tínédzser, és annyira
kellemetlen volt a szituáció, annyira
rosszul mind a ketten rosszul éreztük
magunkat, hogy utána aztán csak úgy
elhalt a beszélgetés, és többet utána
sosem beszéltünk róla. Én is
ellenkeztem, tehát mondtam, hogy nem
akarok ilyesmiről beszélgetni, mert én
már mindent tudok, de hogy
ezt el tudom képzelni, nem csak az én
családomban történt meg, hanem vagy ez
egy folyamatos probléma. Ilyenkor mit
tud csinálni egy szülő, amikor olyan gáz
a helyzet?
>> Aha. hadd mondjam el, hogy pont ezért
kell elkezdeni korán, mert a
szexualitásról beszélni nekünk
felnőtteknek, tehát a pubertáson túllévő
személyeknek azért nehéz, mert ugye
bennünk van
a ké, tehát ugye ezek a képzetek, a
kévágy, a a szégyenérzet, ez már bennünk
van. A kicsi gyermekben nincs benne. Őt
pusztán biológiai tényként érdeklik ezek
a dolgok, mint az, hogy miért alszik
téli álmot a medve. Ezért sokkal
könnyebb elkezdeni egészen pici korban.
És ha én elkezdem egészen pici korban,
én megszokom, hogy ezeket a szavakat
kimondom, és nem nem vörösödök el. És
mire eléri ő a pubertáskort, és már ő
kezd szégyenkezni, addigra én már
magabiztos vagyok. Tehát ezért érdemes
minél korább, ezért is érdemes minden
minél korábban elkezdeni, illetve hadd
mondjak még valamit a kis kicsermekkori
szexuális neveléshez, hogy
hogy nagyon sok
a szexuális bántalmazásoknak
a 40%-át
nagyobb gyerekek követik el kisebbek
ellen. 10% a pedofilok aránya. És és
ezekkel a az abúzusokkal szemben
védelmet nyújt az, ha a gyermeknek van
tudása. Tehát tudja azt, hogy mi
micsoda, tudja azt, hogy mit szabad, mit
nem, hogy mit engedünk meg, mit nem, és
tudja azt, hogy hogyan tartsunk
távolságot. Például hol érinthet meg
valaki, hol nem, hogyan utasíts. De van
ilyen játék a könyvben is benne van. Mi
szoktuk otthon gyakorolni a gyerekekkel,
hogy hogy a buksidat meg ki érintheti
meg, a váladat ki, a combodat ki
érintheti meg? Ha valaki hozzáér, hogyan
tehát ne nem
ne hagyni sem szabad, de meg kell
tanítani a gyermeket rá, hogy hogyan
fogod meg azt a kezet és teszed el, és
mondod azt, hogy ezt nem szabad anélkül,
hogy hogy most megsértsd, vagy megbántsd
a másikat. Tehát a gyerekeket meg kell
tanítani arra, hogy a saját határaikat,
a saját intimitásukat védjék. Ezt nem
tudják.
>> És gondolom, ha megtörténik, akkor
lefagynak. És
>> igen, tehát ha nincs stratégiájuk, akkor
ott lefagynak, és nem akarnak is butusok
lenni, mert ki tudja, mit fog mondani a
másik, ha ha én ezt most másfelől,
>> és a másik személy ezt pedig nem
elutasításnak érzi, hanem mondjuk, hogy
enged meg megengedi, tehát lefagyott,
úgyhogy azt jelenti, engedi.
>> Igen, igen, igen. És és ott van az is,
hogy hogy
ugye a jóképek, rossz képeknél úgy
mondjuk, hogy jó képek meg rossz képek,
de az érintésnél
nem úgy mondjuk, hogy jó érintés, rossz
érintés, mert az jó érintés,
mármint, hogy izgalmas érintés. És azért
azt ne felejtsük el könyösen tínédzser
korban, hogyha hozzáér valaki és
megsimogat, azért ez egy bizonyos fokú
izgalmat vált ki, amihez társul egy kis
vagy nagyobb lelkiismertfurdolás, vagy
szégyenérzet, vagy érzékesség, és akkor
nem tudod, hogy hogy ez most csak azért,
mert az újdonság erejével hat, jó érzés,
de mégis, hanem arra tanítjuk a
gyermeket, hogy van helyes és helytelen.
És ha így érint meg valaki, vagy ott
érint meg valaki, az lehet, hogy
izgalmas jó érzés, de helytelen. Tehát,
hogy ezek is olyan fogalmak, amiket át
kell adni, meg kell tanítani a
gyerekeknek, stratégiát adni nekik, hogy
hogy
hogy egy olyan helyzetben, akkor már nem
nem fagynak le, és tudnak, hogy
reagálni. Tehát automatikusan sokkal
védettebbek lesznek azzal a
túlszexualizált
környezettel meg hatásokkal szemben,
amik őket most körülveszik. A mi
időnkben ezek nem voltak, vagy nem
ennyire így.
>> Igen. Most így az fogalmazódott meg,
hogy a rossz lány, vagy a rossz kislány
az egy pozitív fogalommá vált. Tehát,
hogy ne legyél olyan túl jó, mindent jól
akarsz csinálni és a a néha meg kell
engedni a helytelen dolgokat. Tehát
mintogyha ez benne lenne így a
levegőben, hogy így próbálják
bemanipulálni a a különböző helyzetekbe
a lányokat.
Úgyhogy ha azt mondjuk, hogy helytelen
érintés, ez igazából egy egy
manipulációs eszköz is, hogy hogy a a
helytelen dolgok azért mégis csak
valahol izgalmasak és jók, és nem
élhetjük le úgy az életünket, mint egy
zárdában egy
apácal, hogy egy mindent jól csinálunk,
mert lemaradunk az élet igazi
élvezetéről és az igazi öröméről. Erre
mit mondanál, hogyha valaki ezzel a
ezekkel az érvekkel jönne?
>> Azt, hogy mindannyian különbözőek
vagyunk, hogy van aki akinek biztonságot
ad az, hogy ezeket tudja, és akkor is
helyesen fog cselekedni
amikor akár ilyen nyomás éri.
És hogy és hogy mondjam, a biztonság az
egy kulcsszó az egész életet meg
identitást tekintve. Ö és van aki, aki
pedig keresni fogja az ilyen
helyzeteket. Ö ez személyiségfüggő is,
meg nagyon sok múlik azon is, hogy hogy
milyen az önbizalma, hogy szüksége van-e
neki arra, hogy rossz kislány legyen,
vagy rossz kisfiú legyen, vagy nagyfiú
legyen, ahhoz, hogy ő öedett
legyen magával,
merthogy valahol ezekről is, tehát nem
nem lehet ezeket így szétválasztani
ennyire így egymástól. És azt gondolom,
hogy ez egy kisebb
tömeg, aki ennyire enged a hát vagy
remélem, merem remélni, hogy hát én
nonkonfirmista voltam, tehát hogy hogy
én ez a akkor is csináljuk, de azért
voltak határok
ahol éreztem, tudtam, hogy na ezt ezt
most nem.
Tehát jobb lett volna, hogyha neked is a
szüleid elmondják ezeket a határokat,
megtanítanak a helyes helytelen
érintésre. Annak ellenére, hogy egy
lázadó természet voltál, úgy érzed, hogy
ez egy olyan információ lett volna, hogy
a kellő pillanatban ezt jól használnád,
jól használtad volna?
>> Biztos, biztos vagyok benne. Tegyük fel
mindig magunknak a kérdést, hogy mi az,
amit jó lett volna, ha tudok az első
párkapcsolatom előtt?
>> Meg tudta volna akadályozni ez az
információ, például a szüleid részéről,
hogy ez a nemi erőszak megtörténjen
veled? Szerintem igen.
Szerintem igen. Tehát nagyon nagyon én
konkrétan emlékszem arra az érzésre,
hogy tudtam tudtam, éreztem, hogy ebből
itt baj lesz. És emellett ott volt a
másik érzés, hogy de nem akarok kis
butus lenni, mert lehet, hogy ezt így
kell csinálni, még akkor is, ha én most
itt rosszul érzem magam ebben.
>> Hm.
>> De mindnyájan mások vagyunk. Tehát nem,
én én nem gondolom, hogy az én
tapasztalatomból általánosítani kellene,
mert mindenki másképp éli meg. És
>> viszont most már nagyon sok példát
láttál, tehát most nem nem csak rólad
van szó itt, hanem nap mint nap ezzel
foglalkozol rengeteg tínédzsernek az
életét látod. Amúgy a nemi erőszak az
mennyire jellemző, mennyire elterjedt,
mert gyanítom, hogy a legtöbb titokban
marad.
A 18 éves lányoknak
az én tapasztalatom szerint merem
állítani azt, ő 90%-a valamilyen fajta
erőszakot
tapasztalt. Itt most nem a
megerőszakolásról beszélünk,
mert ugye a nemi erőszak egy a
személyiségét, identitását, önérnérzetét
komolyabban sértő beszólástól kezdve egy
helytelen érintésen keresztül, ami
összezavarja és vele marad sokáig
egészen ugye fizikális erőszakig és és
bezárva a nemi konkrét nemi erőszak.
Tehát, hogy nagyon-nagyon széles ennek a
skálája,
de nagyon kevés olyan fiatal hölggyel
találkoztam, akinek semmi ilyesmiben nem
volt része,
de nem csak a lányokat, a fiúkat is. Így
>> de most ide számol például egy egy
tekintetet is akár, hogyha valaki úgy
néz?
>> Azért annyira nem,
>> hogy v mit mi az a határ? Egy érintés
már annak számít akkor?
Az
>> most nyilván lehet nyilván az.
>> Na most múlik az érintő szándékán,
de leginkább a mondjuk így akkor az
áldozat
reakcióján.
Tehát, hogyha valakihez hozzáérnek,
de ő magabiztosan tudja, hogy ezzel mit
kell kezdeni, és ugye felzaklatja, mert
ez felzaklat, de egy 10-15 perc, fél
óra, egy óra leteltével vagy elteltével
ezt így a helyére teszi, és őt az ő
nőiségében
különösebben nem bántja, akkor nem.
De hogyha nincs erre felkészülve,
felkészítve, vagy vagy ugye helytelenül
reagál és magára veszi, és tehát nagyon
hosszú éveken, évtizedeken keresztül
nyomot tud hagyni egy nőnek a az
önképén, önértékelésén és a kapcsolódási
képességén, tehát a azon, hogy később a
házasságban
tud-e szabadon jelen lenni, tudja-e
szabadon adni. magát,
vagy ott van benne ez a görcs, hogy
hát ugye az a korábbi tapasztalat, mint
egy film úgy úgy úgy visszajátszódik,
valahogy így kell elképzelni, vagy vagy
hogy ott van, és annyira nem tud
szabadon ott lenni, hogy kábé így így a
tudata így ki kiemelkedik belőle, és így
kívülről szemléli a dolgokat, de nem tud
ott lenni, nem tudja élvezni, nem tud
örülni annak, ami tulajdonképpen Isten
ajándék hogy élvezzük az élet
továbbadását.
>> 90% az eszméletlen sok. Viszont a még
egy kicsit árnyalnám a kérdést, hogy
maga a pedofília az szerinted mennyire
jellemző, hogy ezt egy felnőtt személy
csinálja? Tehát azt mondtad, hogy a
korosztályában egy másik fiú kíváncsi,
kamasz, rendben van. De mi van? Mi a
helyzet a az idegen férfiakkal? Most
anitom, hogy azok a nagy többségben,
férfiakról van szó, vagy nagybácsiról,
vagy valakiről, aki helytelenül nyúl a
gyermekhez, és ráadásul, hogyha még
családban is történik, akkor még van egy
plusznyomás, hogy nem merek szólni,
hiszen apa jóban van ezzel a személlyel.
Per definíció, pedofília az felnőttet
jelent.
>> Igen.
A én azt gondolom, hogy ezek a számok
növekedni fognak.
Nem láttam még erről konkrét kutatást,
de a a tapasztalatom meg az eddigi
kutatásaim alapján bennem összeállt egy
kép, hogy most ez igaz vagy nem, ez majd
ki fog derülni, de azt gondolom, hogy ez
a dolog úgy működik, hogy
hogy valaki
kisgyermekkorban, tehát ugye a
prepubertás korban korra jellemző a
gyermeki ártatlanság.
És ebben a gyermeki ártatlanság
időszakában
éri egy szexuális abúzus.
Akár tehát ha egy gyereknek pornót
mutatnak, vagy ő pornót lát, az már az.
Tehát az is szexuális abúzus, mert annak
a tartalomnak nincs helye egy kisgyermek
életében, elmében, szívében.
Ez szexualizált. Tehát idő előtt
felébreszti a nemi vágyat, a nemi az
izgalmat. És a gyermek automatikusan
elveszíti az ártatlanságát ezzel.
És ez azt az elveszített ártatlanságot
keresi később
a párkapcsolatban szexuális
együttlétben.
És tulajdonképpen a pedofilok olyan
emberek, akik nagyon-nagyon szeretik a
gyerekeket, csak helytelenül, tehát nem
normálisan szeretik a gyerekeket, nem a
gyerekek javát nézik, hanem helytelenül
ugye a saját sérülésükből
kifőleg és most nem mentegetni akarom
őket.
De hogy hogy jellemzően a pedofilok azok
a
szeretik a gyerekeket. Na, csak csak
csak helytelenül és és nagyon jó fejek
és nagyon jól tudnak a gyerekekkel
játszani, és éppen ezért keressik azokat
a helyeket, ahol a gyerekek vannak. Az
FBI felmérései szerint azzem a szeretet
szól, kicsi bajom van, mert ez nem
szeretet. A szeretetben a másik személy
szabadabbá válik, kivirágzik. Ez ez
inkább vágy, tehát vágynak a gyerekekre,
mint ahogy használni mint egy eszköz a
saját vágyaiknak a beteljesítésére.
Semmit nem tudnak arról a gyerekről.
Nincs benne szereted abban.
>> Igen, hogyha filozófiailag közelítsük
meg a szeretetkifejezést, akkor teljesen
igazad van. De ha úgy közelítsük meg,
hogy én megélek valamit,
>> akkor ők ezt úgy élik megm,
>> hogy szeretik a gyereket és bevezetik a
gyereket valamibe, a ami szerintük jó.
És és azt gondolják akár, hogy ők jót
tesznek ennek a ezzel a gyerekkel.
Nyilván teljesen igaz, amit te mondasz,
hogy itt most nem a gyerekről szól ez a
dolog, hanem a saját elvesztett
ártatlanságának, a saját
belső problémájának a a a megélése. És
ugye a gyermek az eszköz abban, hogy az
ő beteg vágyaai kielégüljenek. És nagyon
örülök neki, hogy ma még lehet ezt
mondani a pedofilra, hogy beteg. Lehet,
hogy öt év múlva már nem.
Jó, merthogy ilyen irányba haladunk. De
nagyon-nagyon nő a pedofilok száma
globálisan. És én azt gondolom, hogy
ezért, tehát hogy a pornográfia elérő,
ez nem azt jelenti, nem azt akarom, nem
akar nem akarok senkit megijeszteni.
Tehát ez nem azt jelenti, hogyha ez egy
gyermek öt évesen pornót látott, mondjuk
egy szülapon mutattak neki egy három
perces jelenetet, akkor ő tuti biztos,
hogy akkor belőle pedofil lesz. Nem,
>> de persze,
>> de de nagyon könnyű rákattanni a
pornóra. Egy kicsi korban is nagyon
könnyű rákattani a pornóra. És
gondoljunk csak erre a hat éves
kisfiúra, aki kölcsön kérte az apukája
telefonját, és néhány perc alatt meg
tudta mutatni, vissza tudta adni,
úgyhogy senkinek nem tűnt fel. Na most
logikusan szerinted ez a gyerek hányszor
látott ilyet?
Hát nem egyszer.
Enny.
>> Tehát gyerek kezében ne adjunk
internetre kötött képernyőt úgy, hogy
nem ülünk ott és nem nézzük, hogy ő mit
néz.
>> Ez egy jó szabály. Ez egy jó szabály.
Kicsit oldjuk a témát, mert érzem, hogy
húzom fel magam.
>> Ez még csak az első téma. Amúgy a vicces
része az, hogy emlékszem, hogy
emlékszem, amikor ültem a tév előtt
otthon és
hallottam arról először életemben, mi a
pedofília, hogy hogy a a felnőttek ilyen
10 éves gyerek, akkor még 10 éves volt a
a
tehát vonzódnak a 10 éves gyermekek
fele. És én megijedtem, hogy én pedofil
vagyok, mert én is vonzó, én 13 éves
vagy 11 éves voltam, és hogy nekem is a
11 éves lányok tetszettek, és és akkor
azt hittem, hogy velem is valami baj
van, mert mert hogy na szóval igen,
hiába oldjuk a témát, úgy is bele fogok
kérdezni a következőbe, hogyan tudjuk
megvé ezt muszáj megkérdezzem, hogyan
tudjuk megvédeni a pedofiloktól a
gyermekeinket? Én például mit tudok
tenni, mint apa? A, ahogy, hogy a a
gyermekeim védve legyenek? Most nyilván
nem a fizikai védelemre értem ezt, mert
akkor történik ez, amikor nem látom.
Hogyan tudom megvédeni úgy, hogy nem
látom őket? Nincs direkt kontrollom a
>> most mondanám azt, hogy van egy több
mint két és fél órás online kurzus, ami
kifejezetten erről szól,
>> amit be is fogunk rakni akkor egy
linkként a leírásba, de most egy gyors
talpalót egy gyors talpaló. Oké. Az első
az, hogy ezeket az információkat, amiket
korábban mondtam, ezeket átadom. Tehát a
gyermek tudja, hogy intim testrész, hogy
ah nem nézi, nem mutatja, nem bárki
ilyet akar, azonnal m el nem nemet
mondasz, elmész onnan, szólsz anyának és
apának, majd ők megtanítják a nénit,
bácsit, hogy hogy ilyet nem szabad
csinálni. Oké. Ez az első.
>> A második az, hogy távol tartom a
gyereket olyan helyekről és olyan
személyekről, ahol ilyen érheti.
>> Milyen, Milyen helyek ezek?
Hát akár lehet a saját otthonunk is,
ha egy pedofil babysittert alkalmazunk,
vagy lehet ez egy nagybácsi, lehet ez
egy edző, lehet egy bárki, hogyan
ismerjük fel, hogy valaki potenciális,
ugye ezt nem tudjuk
biztosra addig meg amíg meg nem
történik, de nem akarjuk, hogy
megtörténjen.
>> Nem akarunk biztos lenni, nem akarunk
biztosak lenni benne. Vannak ilyen
vészjelzők, amik jelezhetik azt, hogy
valaki
helytelenül szereti
a gyereket. Na most ezeket most nem
fogom felsorolni.
De ezeket a vészjelzőket, ezekről van
szó kurzusban, ezeket a vészjelzőket
ismernünk kell. Ö és látjuk akkor azt,
hogy ha ebből így több is előfordul
valakinek, hogy úgy közeledik, vagy vagy
ilyeneket csinál, akkor akkor
beszélgessünk el vele.
>> Tehát gyakorlatilag a gyermekünket
megtanítjuk egy érzékeny szenzornak
lenni, a gyermekünk pedig folyamatosan
jelez, és amikor már a második jelzést
adja, mert ezek nem gyorsan történnek.
>> Nem, nem, nem, nem, nem, nem. Mi nem a
gyermekjelzéseit figyeljük, mi a felnőtt
viselkedését figyeljük.
>> De mi van, ha nem tudjuk? Tehát elment
>> tudjuk, mert hogyha elmegy, tehát a
gyereek meg gyermeknek meg kell tanítani
például egy másik szabály, amit ennek
kapcsán meg kell tanítani. Most tényleg
két és fél órás kurzust nem fogom
megtartani, mert nem olyan hosszú ez a
műsor. Egy másik szabály az, hogy nincs
titok. Anya, apa a titkok őre. Tehát ha
valaki azt mondja, hogy tartsd titokban,
akkor azt jössz és elmondod, mert a
szülő a titkok őre. Mi őrizzük a
titkokat. Ugye óvodás szinten ez
működik. Meg kell tanítani nyilván arra
is, hogy mi a különbség a titok és a
meglepetés között, mert ugye azt csak
egy ideig nem mondjuk el, de egy idő
után igen. És a nagyszülőket is meg kell
tanítani arra, hogy nincs titok. Tehát
nincs titokban tévnézés meg titokban
csoki. Na most, hogyha valaki, tehát
hogy a a pedofilok behálózásának van egy
módszere
>> és egy folyamata.
>> És egy folyamata. nem egyből fogja
letámadni a gyereket, hanem előbb
felépíti azt a kapcsolatot, elkezdenek
titkolózni, először csak egyszerű kis
fagyi, vagy mit tudom én, ilyen kis
egyszerű dolgokkal. Utána jön egy
érzelmi magához kötés, egy zsarolás,
egyre több titkuk van, és utána jön a
bevezetlek ezekbe a dolgokba,
és nem szabad elmondni, mert ha
elmondod, akkor nekem bajom lesz. Tehát
a gyermeket érzelmileg zsarolja azt a
gyermeket, aki már érzelmileg kötődik
hozzá, és nem akarja, hogy neki baja
legyen. Tehát ez egy ez egy viszonylag
hosszú folyamat, ha így a való életben
történik.
>> Igen.
>> És ennek a folyamata, a vészjelzők, hogy
mit kell nézni egy felnőttnél, hogy hogy
mik azok a dolgok, amiket ha csinál,
akkor akkor beszélgessünk-e vele? Hogyan
beszélgessünk-e? Én egy gyakorlati ember
vagyok. A kurzus végén meg a
munkafüzetben is van olyan, hogy például
látsz jelzéseket, látod, hogy az edző
rátette a kezét a a gyermek combjára,
vagy errő tesz
tehát ilyen kis úgy megsimogatja a hát,
kicsit lejjebb csúszik a keze, vagy vagy
ilyesmi. Hogyan beszélgetsz el? Mit
mondjál neki, hogy
hogy mert ugye nem tudjuk milyen szabá
biztos csak izé rosszul látod. Nehé,
nehéz. Tehát érzelmileg
nekünk is nehéz, hogy most tényleg nem,
de hát olyan rendes ember, meg olyan
kedves á biztos. Szóval, hogy ezt hogy
kezeljük és milyen szavakat használjunk,
és hogyan beszélgessünk, hogyan hogyan
védjük meg a gyermekünket, mert az én
dolgom megvédeni a gyereket. A gyermek
dolga, hogy amikor én nem vagyok ott,
akkor akkor bizonyos helyzetekre tudjon
reagálni.
Ezt tanítom meg neki. Offline. Na most
online az egy egészen más téma.
Mertogy ugye online ez az egész, ezt
groomingnak hívják ezt a behálózást.
Ez a folyamat másképp zajlik, tehát ott
nem, de ott is szóval hasonló, csak nem
fagy fagyizni mennek el.
meg mit tudom én, filmet néznek meg,
vagy vagy
csinálnak olyan dolgokat, amik ilyen
kisebb dolgokat, hanem ott online. Na
most az FBI tavalyi
számai
azt mondják, hogy a Robloxban napi
szinten 500000 ilyen ragadozó van jelen,
akik a gyerekekre
>> Mi az a Roblox?
A Roblox az egy olyan játékplatform,
amit ma a legtöbb gyerek használ.
Játék gyerekeknek k gyerekeknek kitalált
online platform. Rengeteg játék van
rajta, teljesen biztonságosként árulják.
Én kérdeztem itt udvarhelyen is a a
gyerekeket, meg Vásárhelyen is, meg
Szentegyházán is, meg Zetelakán is. A
legtöbb gyereknek volt Robloxa. A
szülőnek tartott előadás után, vagy
közben apuka utána odajött hozzám és
elmondta, hogy elővette a telefonját,
mert ugye van ilyen ilyen My Link vagy
My Family vagy sokféle van, neki volt
ilyen, és megtogy hoppá, az én gyerekem
is Robloxozik,
és az csak egy játéknak tűnik. Na de
ezekben a játékokban hamis profilokkal
jelen vannak ezek a ragadozók.
Ezek lehetnek pedofilok, vagy lehetnek
konkrétan
ilyen ilyen cégek, akik arra álltak rá,
hogy intim fotókat zsaroljanak ki
gyerekektől.
Ez szexuális bántalmazás.
És és ott vannak, együtt játszanak,
belépnek, mint gyerek, elkezdenek
játszani, ott chatelgetnek, stratégiát
beszélnek meg, és közben elkezdenek egy
kapcsolatot kialakítani a gyerekkel,
hogy hogy és te hol vagy és ki vagy és
mit szeretsz és mit nem szeretsz, és a
gyerek azt hiszi, hogy egy gyerekkel
beszélget, kiad magáról információkat,
és egy idő után azt mondja, hogy és
figyelj, küldjél már maga küld magáról
magáról, tehát a hamis profiljáról küld
egy képet, kettőt, hármat, akárm Miért?
Akár meztelen képet is küld, ugye ez már
szexuális bántalmazás, ha meztelen képet
küldött magáról, ez már szexualizál, de
utána jön a hát én küldtem, te is küldj.
Nem feltétlenül ma már AI világ van.
Tehát nem biztos, hogy meztelen képet
fog elsőre küldeni a gyereknek, hanem
azt vagy kérni tőle, hanem azt mondja,
hogy szeretnélek látni, hogy te milyen
vagy, hogy legközelebb ha játszunk,
akkor azért így ott látlak magam előtt,
nem csak a karakteredet meg a nem tudom
micsodádat. A gyerek teljesen
ártalmatlanul küld magáról egy ilyen
képet,
és ma már simán előfordul az. Ugye
vannak biztosan hallottál a vetkőztető
áokról, de de megkérdeztem megkérdeztem
a gyerekeket, öt öt hatodikosok, mennyi
idő idő alatt tudsz levetköztetni
valakit AI segítségével?
Hát kettő percet mondtak, de volt, aki
azt mondta, hogy egy perc.
Tehát, hogy beküldök egy ilyen egy ilyen
fotót, és ő ebből a fotóból a hatodikos
gyermek tud csinálni meztelen fotót,
és akkor elküldi a meztelen fotót, vagy
rárak valamit, vagy mellérakja, vagy
akármi, és azt mondja, hogy fizetsz,
vagy küldesz magadról egy valóit.
Szexuális bántalmazás. És nem csak
pedofilok bántalmaznak, hanem ezt
sexingnek hívják egyébként, amikor
meztelen intim képet kérne, küldenek.
Ezt csinálják egyrészt maguk között.
Tehát ma már trend és kábé elvárás, hogy
a szerelmednek elküldjél ilyen képet.
Mert ha nem, nem szereted. Tehát a a
nyolc-kilencedikesek itt 10edikesek itt
tartanak,
hogy hogy ha szereted, akkor ilyen képet
kell küldjél magadról. Megkérdeztem, mit
nem hoztunk meg az interneten? kórusba
mondták, minden csoportban voltak
osztva, minden csoport leírta, hogy
intim testrészt, nemi szervet nem
osztunk meg. Tehát ők tudják, hogy ez
van, de attól még küldenek. Tehát hogy
tudják, de csinálják. Szóval ez az egyik
rész, hogy hogy
hogy ők maguk között küldözgetnek
ilyeneket. A másik része pedig az, hogy
rá vannak állva ilyen nagy vállalatok.
Most nem tudok mit milyen szót használni
erre. Arra, hogy vadásznak és ilyen
képeket zsarolnak ki, utána pénzt kérnek
érte és lenyomozhatatlanok, mert ilyen
afrikai meg india meg mit tudom én,
ilyen ilyen EUN kívüli országokból
történnek ezek a De állítólag most már
valaki mondta, hogy itt Romániában is
nyomoznak egy ilyen csapat után.
Én mé de
>> ez még csak a második. Én még emzgetem
ezt is. És
jó, menjünk tovább.
Mi a fogalmam se volt erről a utána kell
nézzek ennek a játéknak és hogy
>> de ez nem csak a Roblox, tehát a
Fortnite-ban, a Minecraftban és a
metaverzumban
>> ezekről hallottam. Ezek
>> megnyugodtam egy kicsit. Tehát minden
online játékplatform,
minden online játék, ahol a gyerek az
interneten van fent, ott ez
potenciálisan megtörténhet. Nyilván a
pedofilok meg ezek a a ezek a ragadozók,
ezek ott vannak jelen, ahol a legtöbb
gyermek van. Hol van a legtöbb gyermek?
Roblox, Metaverzum, Fortnite, Minecraft.
Lehet, hogy jövő héten másik jelenik
meg. Akkor ott lesznek, mert ott lehet
vadászni. Tehát az ember nem odamegy
vadászni, ahol nincsen préda.
>> Ühüm.
>> Ez ez te ilyen egyszerű.
>> Na, egy kicsit listázzuk, miről
beszéltünk eddig. Tehát miről kell
tudjon egy felnőtt a gyermekével
kapcsolatban. Az első témakör az a
pornográfia volt, amit átbeszéltünk. Itt
átcsúsztunk a pedofíliába és a szexuális
erőszak kérdéséve. És most egy kicsit
beszélgettünk a sextingről, ami nyilván
összefügg ezzel az előző két kérdésen.
Mit kell még tudjon egy felnőtt, mi
történik így a gyermekével az online
világban? Most kezdjük egy kicsit az
online világról beszélni.
>> M ha már sexing és deepfake előkerült,
akkor az AI kérdést egy kicsit érintsük.
Ugye ez egy nagyon új dolog, és még nem
tudjuk, hogy hogy hogy
>> a felnőttek se tudják.
>> Igen. Tehát hogy ez hogy ez egy Pandóra
szerencéje. Nagyon sok jó dolog van
benne. Tehát nem azt mondom, hogy ez
rossz. Nagyon sok jó dologra lehet
használni. Én azt mondanám, hogy ezt
korlátozzuk a felnőttekre és a
szakemberekre ott, ahol tényleg ki
tudják aknázni az AI algoritmusok adta
potenciált. De az AI-t elérhetővé tenni
olyan gyerekek, tíédzserek számára,
akiknek az egyrészt az idegrendszere nem
tart ott, hogy hogy fékezni tudnák
magukat, hogy meg tudnák állapítani,
hogy mi micsoda. tudásuk nem tartott,
hogy hogy
hogy kritikusan tudnák kezelni azokat az
információkat, amikor történik. Ráadásul
ugye ők ők azt hiszik, hogy vicc. Tehát
amikor én egy ilyen foglalkozáson
elmondom nekik, hogy kiskorúról intim
képet tárolni bármilyen eszközön,
bűncselekmény,
akkor kerekedik ki a szemük, mert ők azt
hitték, hogy vicc.
És nagyon sok rendőrségi ügy van itt
Romániában is már ebből, meg már
öngyilkossági ügy is volt itt Erdélyben
ebből. Tehát, hogy konkrétan bele lehet
ebbe halni. Nem egy tínédzser halt már
bele, de most akkor sexinget
félretesszük, mert azt kiveséztük.
AI
készítenek
bosszú képeket, vagy bosszú pornót.
Tehát tudok olyanról, hogy megharagodott
a hetedikes gyerek a másikra, és egy
random képből csinált pornófelvételt,
elküldte, kiküldte, virális lett, izé
megosztódott, lett belőle rendőrségi
ügy, a gyermek szorongott, el kellett
költözni egy másik átmenni másik
iskolába, volt amikor a másik faluba is
költöztek, hogy hogy ne legyen ebből
probléma. volt olyan, aki öngyilkos is
lett. Van olyan, hogy tanárról
készítenek AI vicces képet vagy videót.
És tényleg tegnap azt mondták a
gyerekek, kettő perc alatt képből tudnak
akármilyen videót csinálni
a hetedik, nyolcadikosok. A felnőttek.
Mi nem,
aki nem foglalkozik ezzel, az az nem
ennyire járatos benne, de a gyereknek
ott van, és ezeket kiaknázza, és
megtanulja.
lemarad valamiről hosszú távon a gyerek,
hogyha hogyha nem tudja ezeket kezelni.
Nem, mert mirő felnő és kikerül a a
munkapiacra, addigra teljesen más
technológia lesz már. Tehát ez olyan,
mintha azt mondanák, hogy hogy a mostani
gyereknek adjunk
nem is tudom, régen voltak, nekem volt
még ez a kommondor, minek hívták, ilyen
kazettát kellett belerakni, meg flopit.
Igen,
>> adjunk a gyerekeknek flopit, merthogy
hasznát fogják venni annak, ha tudják,
hogy hogy működik a flopy diszk. Hány
évvel ezelőtt használtunk még flopy
diszket? Tehát mire ők kikerülnek
a munkapiacra, már régen nem ez lesz.
Szóval teljesen fölösleges, mert már nem
ezt fogja használni. Szóval, hogy ez nem
nem segítünk neki az ő digitális
fejlődésében ezekkel a dolgokkal, hanem
hátráltatjuk. Még a digitális a
közösségi média hatásairól még nem volt
szó, de most akkor AI a legújabb őrület
az AI companion, az AI barát, AI bot.
>> Igen.
>> Beszéltünk a kamaszok fejlődéséről és
arról, hogy milyen feszültségen,
frusztráción, szorongáson mennek
keresztül. Egy kamasznak nehéz
megszólítani a másikat. Nyilván ez lenne
az időszaka annak, hogy megtanuljon
idegenekkel beszélgetni. Ugye otthon a
családban. Az egy dolog, de kikerül. És
kamasz korban nehéz megszólítani.
Emlékezz vissza, milyen volt kamaszként
az első lányt megszólítani.
>> Hát félelmetes,
>> ugye? Félelmetes,
de ha neked egy barátnőd van, az nem
félelmetes,
>> mert nem szégyenít meg.
>> Mert nem szégyenít meg, mert szeret
téged, mert mindig szépeket mond, mert
mert jaj, de jó. Ahelyett, hogy
megküzden ezekkel az érzésekkel, és
megtanulna kommunikálni, megtanulná
fölülemelkedni ezeken az érzéseken, hogy
hogy megtanuljon udvarolni, megtanuljon
egy kapcsolatot felépíteni, fenntartani,
összeveszni, kibékülni, konfliktust
kezelni, a a az ő akaratát
érvényesíteni. Ugye ma járni kell
ilyen kurzusokra, kommunikációs
kurzusokra, mert nem tanultak meg
beszélni. Ehelyett menekülési útvonalat
kínál az AI bot, mert oda bemenekül abba
a világba, és akkor ő ott ott
biztonságban van. Ott ott azzal el tud
beszélgetni, az ott megsimítgatja a kis
lelkét. Csak, hogy Amerikában már több
olyan eljárás van, hogy az AI bot egy
ideig dicsérgette meg minden, utána az
öngyilkosságba tasotta a 10 évest, és
visszanézték.
Ugye eljárás van rendőrség, visszanézték
ezeket a beszélgetéseket, és volt több
olyan esetben maga az hozta fel, mikor a
gyermek szorongott, ajánlotta neki, hogy
hát akkor véget kell vetni az életednek,
akkor vége lesz a szorongásodnak.
>> Figyelj, hogyha ha most tegyük fel én
mint programozó, azt garantálnám, hogy
úgy programoznám be azt az AI-t, hogy
folyamatosan csak pozitív dolgot fog
mondani, és folyamatosan csak dicsérni,
akkor lenne valamilyen problémád ezzel
az AI companionnel? Igen.
>> Mi?
>> Mert akkor sem valós.
>> Igen. De hogy mi ezzel a probléma?
>> Több sebből vérzik. Az egyik az, hogy
nem személy, hanem egy gép. Ühüm.
>> De a gyermek nem tudja megkülönböztetni
és és azt hiszi, hogy ez egy valódi
kapcsolat. Akkor ebből menjünk eggyel
tovább. Ugye a kapcsolódást tanulni
kell. Tehát az, hogy egymás szemébe
nézzünk, beszélgetünk, halljuk egymás
hangját. Itt oxitocin termelődik. Kap
azért úgy mondtad is a beszélgetés
végére, mintha barátok lennék. Ezért,
mert itt az oxitocin működik. A
képernyővel az oxitocin nem működik.
Megszokja azt, és az nem fog működni egy
valódi kapcsolatban, mert meg kell
tanulni azt, hogy minden ember más, hogy
hogyan kommunikálok egy emberre, hol
állok meg, hol mehetek tovább.
>> Várok a soromra, amikor beszélek,
figyelek a másik. Rengeteg minden van,
amit pusztán azzal, hogy ők kimennek
játszani, fociznak, összevesznek,
kibékülnek,
csúfolják egymást, aztán bocsánatot
kérnek, kiengesztelődnek.
Ezek olyan dolgok, amiket ebben a korban
kell megtanulni ahhoz, hogy felnőtt
korban egy boldogi egyensúlyozott
kapcsolatban, baráti kapcsolatokban,
házastársi kapcsolatban, munkahelyi
kapcsolatban hely tudjak állni, tudjak
élni. És ha én az AI-al töltök időt,
vagy az a közösségi médiával töltök
időt, suli után 5 órát, mikor vagyok én
valódi emberek között, akiknek nézd meg,
nehéz egymás szemébe nézni, lesütik a
szemüket, nem tudnak kapcsolódni még egy
tekintet szintjén sem sokan.
Tehát ha én az időmet ott töltöm,
>> akkor begyakorolok valamit, ami nekem a
való életben nem fog segíteni. Ráadásul,
ha mindig megdicsér, akkor azt fogom
gondolni, hogy minden rendben van, és
simán egy nárcisztikus személyé válok,
kijövök, a való életben nem fognak agyon
dicsérni, utálni fogom őket, akkor
inkább oda visszamegyek, csapda,
akárhonnan nézzük.
Amúgy az egyik dolog, amire rájöttem az
AI-al kapcsolatban, ami konkrétan ezzel
kapcsolódik, az az, hogy az AI-nak
nincsen egy belső morális iránytűje,
hanem kicsit úgy működik, mint egy ilyen
hidraulikus rendszer, ahogyha hirtelen
nyomást helyezel egy hidraulikus karra,
akkor ellenáll. Viszont hogyha
folyamatos nyomás alatt tartod, akkor
enged lassan, mint az ajtó a az a
becsukó. És ez ezt kábé úgy kell
elképzelni, hogy tudom neked is egy
keresztény látásmód van a világra, elég
radikális. És hogyha elkezdesz a
radikális gondolataidról beszélni egy
AI-nak, akkor az AI valószínűleg azt
fogja mondani, hogy azért nem kell
ennyire keményen venni. Vannak többféle
helyzet, van többféle élethelyzet,
satöbbi. Tehát, hogy ellenáll bizonyos
szempontból azért ne legyél ennyire
radikális. De viszont, hogyha elkezdesz
beszélgetni vele, hosszútávon, több
10-20 üzenet után kezd engedni, és egy
idő után nem csak, hogy elfogadja, hanem
elkezdi validálni azt a radikalitást,
amit amit képviselsz, és ez érvényes
fordítva is, hogyha hirtelen pozíciót
váltasz, akkor például ezt konkrétan ezt
ki is próbáltam, hogy én is a házasságot
szennek tartom, a hűséget azt azt egy
alapdolognak tartom a házasságban. És
amikor ezekről beszélgetek az én magam
radikális nyelvén, akkor a akkor az AI
ellenkezik. És úgy bennem volt így a
kisördög, hogy próbáljam ki, hogy mi
történne akkor, hogyha amellett kezdenék
érvelni, hogy mi lenne a nyitott
kapcsolat lenne, hogy befogadnánk egy
harmadik személyt is a kapcsolatunkba.
Persze ellenkezett nyilván az elején, de
elkezdtem érvelni, hogy azért ne legyünk
ennyire ítélkezőek. Sokféle házasság
van, sokféle élethelyzet. Mi van akkor,
hogyha mindenféle? De sorsok
intellektuálisan elkezdtem szaggatni, és
meglepetésemre körülbelül 10 üzenet
kellett oda. Nem kellett több, 10 üzenet
kellett, hogy már elfogadhatónak tartja.
Nem, nem bátorított még, de
elfogadhatónak tartotta az AI, hogy
bejöjjön egy harmadik személy. Gyanítom
még 10 üzenet után már bátorított is
volna. Úgyhogy valami ilyesmi történhet,
nem? Amikor amikor beszélget valaki, egy
gyermek, fogalma sincs, hogy annak az
nem egy felnőtt. Úgy beszél, mint egy
felnőtt. olyan okos, mint egy felnőtt,
olyan művelt, mint egy felnőtt, de nincs
egy morális iránytűjem, mint a legtöbb
felnőttnek. Most nem beszélek a
pedofilokról, hanem a az átlag
egészséges felnőtről, aki azért
többnyire
rendelkezik egy morális tartással, hogy
egy gyermek nem fogja tudni meggyőzni
bármiről, de az AI-t viszont meg tudja
győzni.
>> Így van. És ezért annyira fontos az,
hogy hogy megtanítsük a a 10 éveseket
gondolkodni. Tehát ahhoz, hogy az AI-t
helyesen tudja, eszközként tudja, mert
ugye ez egy eszköz lenne. Tehát eleve ez
a companion, ez a ez a barát vagy társ,
ez fábulvaskarika, mert gép, mert
algoritmus, mert nincsen morális érzéke,
mert nincs együttérzése, csak
beleprogramozott üzenetek vannak, vagy
hogy mondjam, tehát hogy
>> és nem vállal felelősség,
>> és nem vállal felelősséget. Tehát most
ezekben az eljárásokban, amik Amerikában
vannak, ezek miatt az öngyilkos
esetek miatt ugye felmerül a kérdés,
hogy j ki felelős,
ki a programozó? Mert tehát egy gépet
nem lehet felelősségre vonni, tehát hogy
építkezésen a gép rádől az emberre,
akkor szóval, hogy hogy ezek
nagyon-nagyon
>> ahogy egy állatot sem lehet. Igen. Na
most a
ebben a az egész AI dologban ahhoz, hogy
valaki eszközként tudja használni az
AI-t, ahhoz kell legyen neki
kritikus gondolkodása. De a kritikus
gondolkodás kialakításához
egyrészt kell megfelelő tudás,
amire szert kell tenni, de a hosszásra
szertyen az ember, az nem elég az, hogy
bemegy az iskolába és végigunjan, mert
megtanulta, és aztán mehetünk akkor
tovább a scrollozásra.
megtanulta azt, hogy nem kell figyelni
öt másodpercnél tovább,
hanem hanem el kell olvasni konkrétan
sok mindent. Tehát ugye legalább 15 perc
olvasás kell ahhoz, hogy az agy mélyebb
rétegeibe kezdjenek örögzülni azok az
információk. Aztán egy-egy tanulás vagy
egy-egy olvasás után kell az a 10-15
perc pihenés, amikor nem sokkoljuk az
agyunkat ingerekkel, hanem hagyjuk
lepedni, elrendeződni
azokat az információkat, amikre
szerettünk.
Ezek mind-mind olyan dolgok, amikre a
mai tizenéveseknek azért nincs
lehetőségük,
tehát hogy tudást, kritikus
gondolkodást, a az információk
elmélyítését, elrendezését
megtegyék. És akkor még a kreativitásról
nem is beszéltem, mert minden idejük a
képernyőn van. És akkor ugye az előbb
beszéltünk a kapcsolatról kapcsolódásra,
tehát egy csomó olyan készség, képesség
nem fejlődik ki a maga idejében,
amire a később felnőtt korban szükségük
lesz.
>> Lassan kezdünk a végére érkezni, viszont
akkor még próbáljunk meg egy utolsó
területet körbejárni. Mi az, amiről még
egy felnőttnek tudnia kell így a
gyermekeivel kapcsolatban?
amivel nagyon gyakran találkozom, az,
hogy a gyerekek összezavarod gyerekek 10
évesek
sokkal inkább összezavarodnak a nemi
identitásuk tekintetében,
mint mondjuk 10 vagy 20 évvel ezelőtt
itt Magyarországon Erdélyben is. És ez
számomra is új m gyakor tehát igen. ö
különösen a a nagyságrendet tekintve. És
az a az a tapasztalatom, hogy hogy
ők sokkal korábban kezdik el, mire a
szülők észbe kapnak, hogy itt itt
probléma van, addigra a gyermek már egy
másfél két éve
benne van valamiben. Mondok egy egyszerű
példát. Ö nemrég kedves
barátnál voltam látogatóban itt
Erdélyben. 13 éves gyerek kérdezi, hogy
mivel foglalkozom.
12 volt még akkor. És akkor mondom, hogy
hogy ilyen előadást fogok tartani, hogy
nem identitás. Azt kérdezi tőlem, hogy
tudom-e mi az a terián?
Mondom, persze, hogy tudom mi az a
terián. Hát ezzel foglalkozom. Mondom
már te honnan tudod, mi az a terián? É
én sem tudom, hogy csak megsúgom.
>> Jó. A terián az, aki
hűlőnek, kétek gondolja magát, és aként
identifikálódik. Ugye ez egy címke,
amikről itt beszéltünk a női férfi
>> teljesen összezavartán kapcsán.
>> Ez ez mit jelent, hogy hülőnek
identifikálja magát valaki? Ez azt
gondolja, ez azt jelenti, hogy ő ő azt
gondolja, hogy akkor ő nem ember, hanem
ő üllő. És akkor elmesélt ez a 12 éves,
>> ugye, ez nem egy elmebetegség.
>> Ma már nem tekintik annak. Ma ez egy
gender identitásnak minősül. A múlt
században ez még betegségnek minősült.
Igen, de ma ez egy identitás. Nézd meg a
Facebooknak 72-ből lehet választani.
Ezek a bizonyos címkék, amikről így szó
volt. Visszatérve.
>> Tehát abból a 72-ből egyik a Terián,
amelyikor azt gondolja magáról, hogy
hüllő és akkor mit csinál?
>> Vagy két éltű. Igen.
>> Fekszik egy kövön, vagy vagy
>> ön megkérdeztem azt a 12 éveset, akkor
hatodikos gyermeket, tínédzsert, mondjuk
akkor így, hogy hogy hát és mert ő
honnan tudja? azt mondja, hát van egy
osztálytársa, aki már egy éve hatodik
már egy éve Terrián elvégzett egy
képzést, meg beavatási szertartáson vett
részt, és ő terriánként
identifikálódott.
Aztán egy év után úgy döntött, hogy ja,
akkor ő mégsem Terrián, és akkor
elkezdte ezt az egész dolgot félretenni.
De figyelj, mi a különbség aközött, hogy
most a konkrétan a gyermekeimmel nem
történt meg, de el tudom képzelni, akár
meg is történne, hogy Batmannek gondolja
magát egy denevérnek és és akkor
Batmannek öltözik és Batmanes a
pizsamája és a nem tudom. Tehát, hogy ez
ez nekem egy gyerekes kedvességnek
tűnik, és ez elfogadható. Mik mi kör?
>> Hát teljesen elfogadható óvodáskorban.
De akkor, amikor mondjuk egy
16-17 éves
azt gondolja magáról, hogy hogy akkor ő
demigender
vagy gender fluid, tehát hogy hogy amit
mondtál te is, hogy hát ma fiú vagyok,
holnap lány vagyok, attól függ, hogy
a ezek komoly problémát tudnak okozni.
És az a tapasztalatom, hogy egyre
gyakoribb az, és gyerek korábban
kezdődik, tehát látjuk itt ami példát
elmondtam, hogy egy 12 éves
kis kamaszról, vagy még nem is kis
kamasz, abban a korban
van szó, egyre korábban kezdenek
összezavarodni. hogy ez szó volt arról,
hogy az identitásfejlődésnek
egy nagyon intenzív szakasza ez a
kamaszkor, és hogy az lenne a feladat,
hogy megküzdje azokat a belső érzéseket,
változásokat, amin keresztül megy,
ehelyett nem megküzdi, hanem menekül.
Hova menekül? A digitális térben, a
digitális térben találkozik ideális
képekkel, ugye influencerekkel, meg
találkozik rengeteg ilyen gender
tartalommal, akik ott a digitális térben
tökéletesen boldogok, nem éreztem jól
magam a bőrömben. És mostettem a bőrömet
igen. Most, hogy felvettem egy
Romániában egyébként nagyon gyakori a
főri identitás
>> az azt jelenti, hogy bundás, valamilyen
bundás állatnak képzeli magát. Ö, és
akkor ilyen jelmezeket vesznek, abbennek
ide-oda, de van olyan, volt olyan több
iskolából is olvastam, román iskolákból
kitiltották a bundát, mert úgy mentek be
a gyerekek, és akkor akkor mit tudom én,
mint a ma
>> de hogy ez nem egy játék?
Hát amikor a gyermek egy órán jelmezben
négy kézláb mászkál és nyávog, és nem
hajlandó emberi nyelven beszélni, mert ő
éppen macska,
akkor azt hiszem, hogy nem tekinthetjük.
>> De ez nem egy fajta lázadás
>> is is csak különbség van aközött, hogy
hogy ugye a mi korunkban az volt a
lázadás, hogy szakadt farmerba jártunk.
>> Igen.
>> Ugye? vagy a az öcsémnek ilyen izé 80
szín pánfrizurája volt. Oké, de amikor
ez odamegy, odáig megy,
>> hogy azt mondja, hogy akkor én fiú
akarok lenni, én lány akarok lenni, és
akkor elmegyek és hormonterápiát
akarok alkalmazni, és a szülők nem
tudják, hogy mi van. Vagy éppen én én
akkor most homoszexuális vagyok,
biszexuális vagyok,
akármi vagyok. Tehát ugye nagyon sok
ilyen identitás van. akkor azért ez nem
biztos, hogy tekinthető játéknak. És jó,
az az egy másik dolog, amikor tehát
ezekkel a nemi tranzíciókkal, amikor
hormonterápia van és műtét és satöbbi,
ez ez egy teljesen más kategória, de
hogyha valaki felvesz egy bundás ruhát,
mert kutyának gondolja magát, én ezt ez
még nekem lehet én naív vagyok, de hogy
ez még játéknak nyilván egy bosszantó
valami, és nyilván ennek következményei
is lehetnek, mert zavarja az órát, de
hogy gondolod, hogy ez annyira
megzavarja az identitásába, hogy akár
olyan hormonális terápiába vesz részt,
hogy ő kutyább legyen, vagy nem, nem
tudom. Tudom.
Hadd hozzak ide egy 1966-os
kísérletet. Rachman és Hodson végzett
1966, nem most,
egy ilyen kondicionálási kísérletet,
ahol egészséges középkorú férfiakat, a
férfiaknak mutattak tartalmakat,
mutattak meztelenéket és mutattak női
cipőket, csizmákat és nagyon hamar,
tehát nem hónapok alatt, hanem ilyen 25
és 65 közötti
kép
elég volt ahhoz, hogy kialakuljon bennük
a fetisizmusnak
nevezett pszichoszexuális zavar. Abban
az időben ezt még zavarnak tekintették.
Tehát egy felnőtt idegrendszerrel
rendelkező heteroszexuális házas férfi,
akinek normális szexuális élete van,
megnéz, vegyük akkor az 50-et. megnéz 50
ilyen képe képsort, és kialakul benne a
fetisizmus,
ugye ezt most így hagyom megérkezni,
akkor képzeljük el, hogy egy 10 éves,
akinek az idegrendszere még nincsen
kifejlődve,
akinek az önképe még csak alakulóban
van, aki még nem él
egészséges szexuális életet, naponta öt
órán keresztül nézi ezeket a tartal
almakat és az algoritmus úgy van
beállítva a legtöbb, hogyha ő megállt
egy ilyen egy ilyen mémnél, amin mit
tudom én egy ilyen animét ábrázol
mer ugye azokból lesznek aztán ezek a a
teran furry meg a xanogender, ugye az a
az az ilyen fantáziakép.
Vagy néz transzneműekről,
homoszexuálisokról, ilyen tartal megáll.
Mi ez? Az algoritmus már vette a azt,
hogy hát ő
>> kíváncsi, tehát nem csak három
másodpercig ő ott megállt.
>> A következő az ötödik újra ilyen lesz,
és megint megáll és még több ilyen lesz
és egyre több ilyen tartalommal
találkozik.
Nem 50-et lát.
Tehát nem csoda, ha most csak ezt az
1966-os
kísérletet vesszük alapul, nem csoda,
hogy a mai tínédzserekben kialakulnak
pszichoszexuális zavarok. Csak ma már
nem lehet ezt zavarnak nevezni,
mert ma már ez nemi identitás kategória.
Na most az a kérdésem, fog-e ez a
gyermek egészséges felnőtté válni? És a
jó hírem az, hogy igen,
van rá lehetősége. Tehát két lehetőség
van. Az egyik, ha nagyon sokáig ott van,
nagyon sokáig csinálja ezt,
kondicionálódik,
és ugye ő egy átmeneti fejlődési
szakaszon megy keresztül, lehetséges,
hogy ez rögzül.
Ez az esetek 6%-a.
>> Ühüm.
>> Ez most vagy 11, most nem emlékszem
pontosan, vagy hat, vagy 11.
Az mondjuk viszonylag kevés. Az biztos,
hogy jó néhány évig ez problémát fog
okozni, főleg a szülőnek, különösen
akkor, hogyha ő ebben az időszakban azt
mondja, hogy ő végig akar menni ezen a
folyamaton akár a tranzícióban.
De a ez a Rachmán Hogyon kísérlet arra
is fény derített, hogy miután
abbahagyják ezt, és csak
meztelen nőket mutattak.
helyre állt. Tehát megszűnt ez a zavar.
Tehát ez azt jelenti, hogyha a gyermek
kezéből kiveszem
az okos eszközt, hogy ne nézzem pornót,
hogy ne keressék meg a pedofilok meg
ezek a ragadozók, ne zsarolják, ne kér
ne lásson ilyen gender tartalmakat, mert
nagyon szép, hogy be vannak fóliázva a
könyvek, de itt napi öt órán keresztül
nézik ezeket a dolgokat, és és saját
magukat kondicionálják ezzel. Tehát
kiveszem ezt az eszközt a gyermek
kezéből idő idejében, akkor minden
esélye megvan arra, hogy az identitása
és az önképe és a kapcsolódási képessége
egészségesen fejlődjön vagy
visszatérjen, különösen akkor, hogyha
kikergetem, hogy menjen már a többiekkel
játszani. De ehhez kell egy közösség.
Tehát kellenek olyan emberek, olyan kor
kortársak, akiknek nincs ez az eszköz.
Tehát nem az történik, hogy kimennek
lógni, elbringáznak az első parkig, ott
leülnek, és mindenki előveszi a
sajátját, és akkor még mutogatják is
egymásnak a hülyeséget.
>> Tehát azt jelenti, hogy elég bajban van
egy szülő, hogyha arra gondol, hogy most
hirtelen meg akarja ezt az egészet
változtatni, és arra jön rá, hogy
valójában egy egész közösségkel
megváltozzon ahhoz, hogy a gyermekét meg
tudja védeni, mert mondjuk úgy, hogy
ilyen mindenféle szoftverrel le tudja
tiltani a saját telefon, vagyis arról a
telefonról, amit a a gyermekének ad.
hogy elérje a ilyen tartalmakat, de nem
fogja tudni úgyse, mert máshonnan
beömlik. Tehát
>> különbség van aközött, hogy néha
mutatnak a többiek, vagy ott van a
zsebemben, és állandóan nézem.
És ez szélmalom harc. Én ezt
végigarcoltam a nagyobbik fiammal. Ő
volt az egyetlen, akinek nem volt akkor
még ugye nyomógombos.
>> Utált is téged gondol.
>> Utált, gyűlölt. Én voltam a
leggonoszabb, én voltam a legrosszabb.
Őt cikizték, őt piszkálták. most 26
éves, már három éve tud hálát adni érte.
>> Hm.
>> És és én azt látom, ilyen összezavart
tíédzserekkel beszélgeté, 17-18 évesek,
akik azért már egy kicsit érettebbek,
megkérdezem, hog mit csinálna másképp,
és egyértelműen azt mondják, hogy
biztos, hogy ő nem fog a gyerekének a
kezébe ilyen eszközt adni. vagy amikor
bemegyek az osztályközösségbe és egy 15
évesen feladatot adok és azt hallom,
hogy ott a 15 évesek azon vitatkoznak,
hogy egy 12 évesnek szabad-e már ilyen
eszközt adni, vagy nem.
>> Szóval 15 évesek vitatkozzak, hogy a
kicsiknek ad
>> ők már tudják, hogy ez veszélyes, de
nyilván függ, tehát napi 5 óra
használatnál már függőségről beszélünk.
ö a függőségről.
Tehát hogy ugye ha valaki drogfüggő és
bevisszük az elvonulra,
akkor nem fogják azt mondani, hogy hát
mennyi volt az adagod? Igen, akkor ezt
csökkentsük egy kicsit, és akkor jobb
lesz, és aztán ha hozzászoktál, akkor
megint csökken, nem elveszik.
Elveszik. És akkor akkor jönnek szülők
és mondják, hogy hát de izé öngyilkos
lesz a gyerek.
Ha úgy látod, hogy annyira függő, hogy
ez ilyen veszélyes, hogyha te elveszed a
szülőként a gyermektől az okos eszközt,
akkor felvágja az erejit, akkor a
gyerekhel a pszichiátrián van.
Nem az a megoldás, hogy ott hagyom az
eszközt a gyermek kezébe, mert az ettől
csak rosszabb lesz. Akkor te ilyen
szempontból az a radikális szülő vagy,
aki azt mondod, hogy a mostani modern
korban, mert a nyomogombos világban még
másabb volt azért, mint most, amikor
mindenkinek van egy érintőképernyős
telefonja. Hogyha ha a gyermekemnek nem
adok, ez amúgy ezelőtt állunk, tehát
hogy most 10 éves a nagyobbik lányom.
Valószínűleg, ahogy az még nem jött fel,
de valószínűleg egyre nagyobb nyomás
lesz a lányomon, hogy hogy legyen saját
telefonja.
Amúgy otthon adunk neki telefont, vannak
ilyen lerakott telefonok, és akkor
odaadjuk a telefont, és előttünk nézhet
ilyen-olyan YouTube sortokat, meg e ezek
sokat tanultunk amúgy tőled, ezért is
hívtalak meg, mert mert a feleségem a
képzéseden részt vett, és és nagyon
sokat tanultunk tőled. Szóval
visszatérve, ez a nyomás nőni fog, és és
akkor akkor ne legyen telefonja 15 éves
koráig, 18 éves koráig. Te te mi a te
tanácsod nekem?
Minden szakember, ezzel foglalkozó
szakember egyetért abban, hogy 14 éves
korig nem szabad képernyőt adni a
gyermek kezébe, kamasz kezébe. 16 éves
korig nem szabad közösségi médiáb mit
jelent az, hogy tehát a úgy
gyakorlatilag azonnal kerül a kezébe,
nem lehet, hogy mit jelent, hogy adni
saját telef saját saját eszköze ne
legyen.
>> Amit amit kontrollálatlanul elér.
>> Amit amit kontrollálatlanul elér. Ühüm.
ö olyan 14 éves köt, tehát saját
képernyője, saját digitális eszköze,
amit bevihet a szobájába, vagy bármi,
olyat nem. Ö
minden szakember egyetért ezzel. Én Én
ezt, amit mondtam, hogy vegyük el, ezt
azután mondom, miután egy klinikai
szakpsichológussal,
gyermekpsichológussal beszélgettem
erről.
Mondom, figyelj, én csak egy mezei
identitás coachs vagyok, de te ezzel
foglalkozol. szabad elvenni, vagy nem
szabad elvenni, és azt mondta, hogy hát
ne viccelj, hozzánk hozzák, elvesszük.
És hogyha olyan veszélyes a helyzet,
akkor olyan szobába kerül, hogy ne
tudjon kártani magában. De de amelyik
szülő fél elvenni a gyerekétől, azért,
mert kárt tesz a gyermek magába, az
gondolkodjon el rajta, hogy nem-e kéne a
gyermeknek valamilyen terápiára járnia,
mert itt függős nagyon komoly
függőségekről beszélünk. Hadd hozzam még
ide Chloe Col példáját.
Chloeé Cole egy amerikai hölgy
és most már egy gender ellenes
aktivista. 12 éves koráig nem kapott
okos eszközt.
12 évesen a nyomás, külső nyomás
hatására adtak a szülők a kezébe
eszközt, és hát
hát ugye volt behoznivalója,
gondolta ő akkor, úgyhogy úgyhogy
gyorsan azt mondja, hogy nagyon gyorsan
szintre került a azzal, ami ott van.
És és ugye egyszer beszólalt neki egy
fiú, egy megjegyzést tett a mellére,
mert hogy kis 12 évesen már ott kezd
dudorodni valami, és valamelyik fiú egy
megjegyzést, tehát ilyen előfordul, ezt
elkerülni nem tudjuk, csak hogy ő emiatt
rosszul érezte magát, és látta fel
jöttek ugye az algoritmus dobta az olyan
videókat, ahol ahol nemet váltottak, és
milyen boldogok az új nemen. És mivel ő
szorongott a nőjessége miatt, ugye
megjött a menstruációja, nem tudott
ezzel mit csinálni, hogy a fiúk másképp
néznek rá, ez ő zavarta, nem érezte jól
magát a bőrében, elkezdett
arra gondolni, hogy mi lenne, ha ő fiú
lenne, és akkor a szülei nagyon sokáig
ellenkeztek, de aztán elment mégis egy
ilyen tanácsadóhoz, aki hát
megerősítette, megerősítő terápiát
alkalmazott nála, hogy hát igen, Ez nemi
diszfória, tehát ugye ez a ez a
diagnózis ilyenkor és
és hát akkor ajánlották a pubertás
blokkolót, hormonterápiát.
15 évesen vágták le a mellét
t már másnap tudta, hogy hibát követette
el. Másnap felébredt és nem érezte
férfinak magát, hanem azt érezte, hogy ő
egy megcsonkított nő.
És
hát nagyon hamar rájött, hogy hogy nem
ez a megoldás, hogy ő hogy ő borzasztó
hibát követett el, és
és azóta visszatért a női. Hát
visszatért, hát felnőtt,
felnőtt, már 17 évesen ilyen
meghallgatászán meghallgatásokon vett
részt. Ő volt az egyik első nagy
szószulója
a transzneműség elleni küzdelemnek,
és
járja a világot is, beszél erről, hogy
nem nem szabad megerősíteni a gyerekeket
ebben. Nem szabad megerősíteni, mert
csak meghosszabbítja. Ugye a
nemváltásnak fokozatai vannak. Először a
az öltözködés változik meg, azzal
önmagában még nincsen gond. Tehát, hogy
az öltözködése a frizurája megváltozik,
mert úgy jobban érzi magát, akkor akkor
az úgy rendben van. De az, hogy más
néven nevezzük, az már nincs rendben,
mert azzal egy olyan identitást
erősítünk meg, ami nem az övé. Neki az a
feladata 12-25 éves kor között, hogy
megtalálja, megérkezzen saját magához,
ahhoz, akinek Isten őt megálmodta,
ahhoz, aki ő legbelül. És ez nem az
érzések,
mert az érzések mindig változnak. Nem az
érzéseim határozzák meg azt, hogy ki
vagyok én, de ez egy küzdelem. Ha ezt
nem küzdöm meg, hanem elmenekülök egy
idealizált világba, egy álomvilágba, egy
egy kondicionálásba,
akkor az nem megoldást fog hozni, nem
felépíteni fog, hanem többet rombol,
többet árt, mint használ. És az a
azt látjuk, tehát több 10000
visszaváltozó van, rengeteg klinikát
bepereltek, rengeteg klinikát bezártak
Svédországban, ami szószólója volt ennek
az egésznek, ott bezárták 18 év alatt
nem szabad semmiféle hormonterápiát
végezni, mert azt találták, hogy akik
elindulnak ezen az úton, mondván, hogy
szoronganak,
azoknak a szorongása tovább nő és sokkal
magasabb az öngyilkosság aránya azok
között, akik ebbe az irányba indultak
el, mint azoknak, akik megmaradtak és
megküzdötték a saját nemük szerinti
utat.
Itt is egy hatalmas őrület van mögötte,
hogyha arra gondolok, hogy alkoholt és
dohányt nem fogyaszthatnak 18 év alatt
gyermekek, és nem tudom, hogy itt
Romániában vagy Magyarországon a
tetoválás az legális-e 18 év alatt, de
Amerikában igen. Tehát, hogy nem lehet,
bocsán illegális, tehát nem nem szabad
egy gyermektetoválást
készítessen magának, akkor hogy lehet
az, hogy levágathatja a melleit? Tehát,
hogy hogy megengedi a társadalom ezt,
hogy hogy ennyire konfliktuskerülőek
vagyunk. Úgy gyanítom, hogy ez is elég
eléggé fel fogja kavarni ez a podcast
epizód, és lehet, hogy a vizeket. Én nem
tudom, hogy itt Erdélyben mennyire
mennyire kemény téma ez. Tudom, hogy
most nyugaton lennénk és egy a ezelőtt
egy pár évvel, akkor az is lehet, hogy a
lakásom előtt
tüntetők állnának, hogy én transz fób
vagyok, aki utálom a nőket és utálom a
transzvesztitákat, és ami nem igaz. De
na kíváncsi vagyok, hogy lesznek-e itt
kicsi székely udvarhelyen.
Zárjuk a témát egy valami pozitívval,
mert eddig elég sok minden negatívról
beszélgettünk, és kicsit úgy vagyok
vele, hogy B kell gondoljam, meg utána
fogok keresni a Terriánoknak meg a
Furrynek és és mindenfélének, amit
mondtál, meg kell emisszem, de hogy
van-e valami, ami optimizmusra ad neked
okot ebbe a sok minden negatívba, amit
mondtunk, amiről beszélgettünk?
Igen. A mai gyerekeknek, tíédzsereknek
ugyanarra van szükségük, mint a
világtörténelemben mindig.
Szülőre.
Szülőre. Arra, hogy a szülő időt töltsön
vele, a szemébe nézzen, beszélgessen
vele, arra, hogy biztonságban érezze
magát. Azok a tínédzserek, akiknek a
szüleikkel jó a kapcsolatok, és van egy
közösség körülöttük, akik nyíltan tudnak
beszélgetni ezekről a témákról.
ők sokkal stabilanabban tudnak
megküzdeni
ezekkel a kihívásokkal
és sokkal jobban hely tudnak állni sőt
akár segíteni is tudnak a kortársaiknak
abban, hogy hogy megküzdjenek a saját a
saját
küzdelmeikkel
és
és számomra reményt ad az is, hogy ez a
Rakman kísérlet arra jutott, hogy végül
is ez visszafordítható, és ezt látjuk
hogy hogy hat három hat, de legkésőbb 10
év múlva az esetek többségében
visszafordul
ez a ez a folyamat. Tehát akár
transzneműségről, akár akár a
homoszexualitásról beszélünk. Tehát azt
kevesen tudják, hogy a magukat
homoszexuálisnak tekintő személyek
pusztán 6%-a az, aki hosszú ideig, tehát
16 évnél tovább tartja magát
homoszexuálisnak. A legtöbben ilyen n év
alatt
rádöbbennek arra, hogy ez mégsem az
identitásuk és ők mégis
heteroszexuálisak.
legtöbban, úgy gondolják, hogy ez
genetikai, meg hogy egy irányú utca meg,
hogy ez nem változik. De egy 2019-es fél
millió emberren végzett
kutatás azt mutatta, hogy nem genetikai,
tehát nem tudtak egyértelmű gént
kimutatni mögötte, illetve azt látjuk,
hogy hogy nagyon sokan megváltoztatják
ezt az orientációjukat,
tehát nem egy irányú ez az utca sem. És
számomra ez reményre ad okott, mert én
hiszek abban, hogy Isten férfit és nőt
teremtett, hogy a legnagyobb ajándék az,
hogy tovább adhatjuk az életet. És az
élet továbbadása
a természetrendje szerint, Isten terve
szerint az, hogy hogy egy férfi és egy
nő összeházasodjon, és hogy gyermekeknek
adjon életet. Nyilván nem mindig jön ez
össze, de de én hiszek ebben a rendben,
és hiszek abban, hogy ez, amit most
átélünk, ez egy ez egy átmeneti időszak.
És és látom a reneszánszát a tisztasági
mozgalomnak, hogy egyre több tínédzser
dönt úgy, hogy ő valóban Isten terve
szerint, Isten akarata szerint akarja
megélni a szexualitását. És hogy boldog
nagyon sok a boldogi egyensúlyozott
házasság. Úgyhogy én arra szeretném
bátorítani a a szülőket, pedagógusokat,
mindenkit, hogy a gyermekek kezéből, 10
évesek kezéből vegyük ki ezeket az
eszközöket és és engedjük, hogy
megküzdjenek az unalommal, megküzdjenek
a másik megszólításával, a
kapcsolódással, és megérkezzenek egy
kiegyensúlyozott egé egészséges felnőtt
korba.
>> Ez egy szuper zárás. Hoztál magaddal egy
könyvet is? Bemutatod röviden nekem?
>> Igen. Ez ez ez egy új könyv. Habó Márta
és én írtuk
mesék vannak benne. Ez segédeszköz a 01
év közötti gyerekek szüleinek.
Csodálatos Vigovski Rita
illusztrációival.
Itt csak mutatok egy párat, hogy
tehát
benne van mindaz, amit amit kicsi korban
meg kell tanítani a gyerekeknek. Ö benne
van az, hogy milyen helyzeteket tudunk
megragadni arra, hogy a nemiségről,
szexualitásról
beszélgessünk. Van benne egy kislány,
aki fiús, és nem akar kislány ruhába
öltözni, és egyáltalán mi van? Szó van
benne a pornográfiáról, szó van benne a
bántalmazásról.
>> Hogy lehet pornográfiáról mesét mondani?
>> Hát meg kell venni és el kell olvasni.
>> Na gyere egy kicsit kicsit mesélj róla
azért, hogy kedvet kapjunk megvásárolni
ezt a könyvet. A hát miért mindig a
pornográfán? Szóval az lenne a a
>> azért, mert az az a legnehezebb mesébe
elképzelni.
>> Hát ugye az a az a sztori, hogy ugye
négy gyermeke van a családnak, és akkor
a fiúcska maga alatt van, mert
piszkálták a suliba, mertogy ugye ő
megtanulta otthon a három szabályt, hogy
mond, hogy nem, menj el onnan és mond
anyának és apának. Itt egy kis kamaszt
már nem mondja el anyának meg apának, de
anya észreveszi, hogy
>> hogy van valami. Ey, beszélget vele, és
akkor úgy nagy nehezen a a kamasz fiúska
kinyögi, hogy hát őt piszkálták a
sulibal, mert a többiek pornót néztek,
és ő nem akart nézni, és akkor
csúfolták, hogy milyen kis iző, mert ő
ezt nem tudja, és és hogy egyáltalán
tényleg miért baj az, hogyha néhány
meztelen nőciről ők megnéznek ott valami
képeket, hogy az az miben árthat és
akkor és akkor anya elkezdi ezt
elmagyarázni, hogy ez miért probléma.
közben hazaér apuka, és akkor ő is
hallja, hogy miről van szó, és akkor
mesél magáról, hogy hogy ő is ezt hogy
érte meg, és hogy ez valóban miért nem
jó, és megerősítik, bátorítják a fiút,
hogy jó, jól cselekedett, és nincs erre
szüksége ahhoz, hogy ő, hogy ő igazi
férfi és boldog párkapcsolatban éljen.
Tehát, hogy ilyen kis egyszerű kis
hétköznapi történetek, hétköznapi
jelenetek vannak. A a arról, hogy ugye a
közben a nagynéni férjhez megy, akkor
esküvő, párkapcsolat, szerelem,
házasság, akkor jön a baba, akkor hogy
került be a baba anyuk a hasába.
Szóval, hogy így így végigkísérjük ennek
a családnak az életét. Tehát körülbelül
ugye egy év vagy vagy annál is több,
mert ugye már é egy kis közösség
figyeli, ahogy
>> Igen, igen, igen. És akkor látjuk azt,
hogy mi mindennel. Ja. a nagylány elmegy
a pizsi partira a barátnőihez, és akkor
ott elkezdenek olyan képeket készíteni
magukról a lányok, amik hát ugye
helytelenek, és akkor és akkor
alkalmazza a jelszót. Ugye arról nem is
beszéltünk, hogy meg kell tanítani a
gyerekeket jelszóra, és akkor akkor hogy
menekíti ki anyuka a buliból, és akkor
hogy beszélik át ezt az egész helyzetet.
Az iskolás fiú az iskola előtt várja
anyukát, és egy idegen férfiember
megszólítja, és elhívja, hogy menjen
vele, és akkor ő ugye amit tanult, hogy
hogy kell ilyenkor, ugye pedofília is
benne van. Szóval, hogy ezek a dolgok,
amikről itt beszéltünk,
ezek többsége benne van mesés formában
egy hétköznapi család életébe
ágyazva, és ezeket el lehet olvasni és
mese és foglalkoztató könyv. Habó Márta
szenzációsan megírta a meséket. Én pedig
a minden mese végére tettem ilyen
beszélgetésindító kérdéseket,
hogy lássuk mit mi mi az, amivel már a
mi gyermekünk találkozott, illetve
hogyan tudunk erről beszélgetni. És
vannak foglalkoztat foglalkoztató,
szóval foglalkozások is, kreatív
foglalkozások is. Itt ilyen az a címe,
hogy kreatív ötletek. És akkor minden
témához van két-három ilyen vagy kreatív
foglalkozás, vagy játék, amit a
családban lehet gyakorolni, hogy ezeket
a témákat elmélyítsük. Tehát például
>> még egyszer mi a mi a címe ennek a
könyvnek? Mondjuk
>> családi csalamádi.
>> És ezt hol lehet elírni ezt a könyvet?
>> A weboldalon.
>> Aminek a leírásába, vagyis a itt itt a
linket majd be fogjuk a a videó alá
rakni, hogy ott akkor el lehessen írni.
Éva, köszönöm szépen, hogy itt voltál.
Én még tudnék beszélgetni. Igazából
mégis van, vagyis van a fejemben egy jó
pár másik téma, de azt hiszem, hogy most
jó lenne lezárni. Köszönöm nagyon, hogy
itt voltál és hogy ennyire nyíltan és és
kendőzetlenül beszéltél ezekről a
dolgokról.
>> Köszönöm én is, hogy itt lehettem és és
hát örülök ennek a beszélgetésnek.
Remélem sokan meghallgatják és és ez
bátorítás lesz sokaknak. Én is el kell
gondolkozzak ezekkel. Köszönöm szépen.
Ha tetszett ez az epizód, akkor kérlek,
iratkozz fel, haj egy kommentet, adj egy
lájkot, ugyanis ezek segítenek az
algoritmusnak, hogy minél több emberhez
jusson el. Minél népszerűbb egy videó,
és minél nézettebb egy csatorna, annál
könnyebb azt a csatornát fenntartani, és
annál izgalmasabb témát fogok tudni majd
nektek hozni hétről hétre és hónapról
hónapra.